OVERSIGHT HEARING
WITH BUDGET SUB SIX IN THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION TO DISCUSS THE
STATUS OF THE STATE'S RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
LET ME JUST READ A COUPLE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS- WE ARE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS IS ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
MEMBERS FROM BOTH COMMITTEES.
SOME MEMBERS WILL BE JOINING
REMOTELY. WILL HAVE MINIMUM-
CONTINGENT OF STAFF A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO
WE CAN MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF
SPACE. WE ARE FOLLOWING STRICT
PHYSICAL DISTANCE DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITOL.
FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I WILL RESTATE
THAT WHEN PUBLIC FROM BEGINS IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WAS TO SPEAK IT WILL RAISE
YOUR HAND THAT ALLOWS HIM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC'S RESPECT
PHYSICAL DISFIGUREMENT TOUCH
MICROPHONE YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM WHAT YOU
WANT TO PUBLIC COMMENT IS DONE
OR YOU CAN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT-
I AM PLEASE CONTINUE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING. PARTICLES
AT THE PALACE ON THE AGENDA AND
THE L. A. O. R. APPEARING
REMOTELY FROM THEIR RESPECTIVE
OFFICES OR BY PHONE. THERE ARE
PUBLIC STATIONS AVAILABLE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC TO COMMENT. THE GENDER
CONTAINS LOCATIONS OF THESE
STATIONS INCLUDING ONE IN
CAPITOL PARK. YOU ENCOUNTER ANY.
PLEASE CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO OH NINE
NINE. THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO.
SUBMIT WRITTEN. TESTIMONY AND
BUDGET SUB SIX. AT THE A. S. A.
DOT A. GOV. LET ME JUST TURN IT
OVER TO. MIGHT FOR LITERACY IF
HE HAS ANY OPENING REMARKS MR.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME TO THE
FIRST ASSERTED DURING
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS BETWEEN
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION AS WELL AS THE
BUDGET SOME PRASAD COMMITTEE
NUMBER SIX FOCUSING ON THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. LET ME FIRST
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE CHAIRMAN TANG AS WELL
AS A STAFFER. THEIR HELP IN
PREPARING FOR THIS HEARING FOR
THE MEANINGFUL PARTNERSHIP. THE
MORE THIS MORNING WILL FALL
THIS MORNING WILL BE FOCUSING
ON THE STATE'S OPERATIONAL
EFFORTS TO CONTAIN THE PANDEMIC
INVEST INVEST EMERGE DISASTER
FUNDS PREPARATIONS FOR
DISTURBING THE VACCINE AND OUR
ONGOING EFFORTS TO PROCURE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
FOR CALIFORNIANS. I KNOW TWENTY
TWENTY IS THE CHALLENGING YEAR
MAY LEVELS FOR ALL OF YOU
PRESENTED TODAY IN A WASHING OF
YOUR HARD WORK AND EFFORTS TO
CONTAIN THIS PANDEMIC ARE MUCH
APPRECIATED. AS WE HEAD INTO
THE WINTER WITH THE NUMBER OF
COVERT NINETEEN CASES IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUING TO RISE
ALONG WITH ANOTABLE UPTICK IN
THE NUMBER OF HOSPITALIZATIONS
THIS IS A- TIMELY MOMENT TO
TAKE STOCK OF OUR- OVERALL
EMERGENCY PREPARATIONS AND
RESPONSE TO DATE. THIS ISN'T
HEARING ABOUT HINDSIGHT BUT
OPTED TO ASSESS WHAT ACTION TO
BE TAKEN TO DATE. AND A MOMENT
TO SHARE THE LESSONS WE'VE
LEARNED SO THAT WE MAY BE
BETTER INFORMED. AND PREPARED
MOVING FORWARD. THANK YOU AGAIN
TO ALL OF OUR PARTICIPANTS AND
TO THE COMMITTEE- BUDGET SUB
SIX FOR THE PARTNERSHIP. LOOK
FORWARD TO. OUR DISCUSSIONS-
AND THE TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COMMENTS FROM AGAIN
YOUKNOW WE ARE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE WE'RE THE MIDDLE THE
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA HAS
APPROACHING CLOSE TO ONE
MILLION COVERT CASES IN NEARLY.
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DEATHS- WE IN
PARTICULAR ARE DISCUSSING HOW
WE APPROACH EMERGENCIES A
TYPICAL EMERGENCY LAST FOR A
FEW DAYS OR FEW WEEKS- THE ONLY
EMERGENCY IN RECENT HISTORY
THAT WENT ON FOR MORE THAN THAT
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WAS THE
STATE DROUGHT. IN OBVIOUSLY THE
RESPONSE WAS A VERY DIFFERENT
KIND OF RESPONSE WE ARE NOT
USED TO HAVING AN EMERGENCY
WHICH TOUCHES EVERY FACET OF
OUR LIVES IN EVERY SINGLE PART
OF THE ENTIRE STATE. SO DOING
SO WHERE CAN WE WANT TO EXPLORE
AND MAKE SURE. THAT WE ARE
AGAIN CONTINUING TO OPERATE A
WALL IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY
BUT WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE AND
RUN THE STATE IN A DEMOCRATIC
FASHION. WITH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY MORE OPENNESS IN
INVOLVEMENT- FROM THE VARIOUS
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT. SO FOR
OUR FIRST PANEL YOU YOU'RE
RECEIVING AN UPDATE OVERVIEW.
OF AVAILABLE IN ANTICIPATED
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDS
PROVIDED TO MITIGATE THE IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC. THE SECOND
PANEL WILL REVIEW THE P. P. ET
CONTRACT PROCUREMENT PROCESS IN
THE AVAILABILITY OF PPE TO
SECTORS. THAT ARE IN NEED. I
THINK THE- OVERALL I KNOW THAT
MYSELF AND ALL MY COLLEAGUES.
WANT TO CAN STOP MAKE SURE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE PROPER
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. AT THE
SAME TIME ENSURE THAT THERE IS
A GREATER COMMUNICATION WITH
THE- DEPARTMENT OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AS WELL AS- WITH THE
LEGISLATURE SO I THINK THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS AGAIN
VERY VERY MUCH. TOP OF MIND FOR
ALL OF US. SO LET US START WITH
THE FIRST PANEL WE HAVE TWO
SPEAKERS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE. HELLO ARE YOU THERE.
IF YOU JUST START TALKING THE
YOU'LL COME ON SCREEN. FOR THE
WHOLE WE HAVE MISS HOLLINGSHEAD
AND MISS PETERS FROM THE LA
OFFICE.
OKAY OF MISS
HOLLINGSHEAD OR MISS PETERS IF
YOU COULD ON MUTE YOURSELF. AND
THEN ONCE YOU START TALKING YOU
WILL APPEAR ON SCREEN.
EVERYONE
ON THE WEBEX WE'RE HEARING A
FROM WE HAVE AN ONLINE IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY KICKED IT OVER TO YOU
AND- SO IT'S JUST IT'S HARD TO
HEAR YOU HAVE TO KIND OF HAVE A
HEARING ON THE SIDE IT LOOKS
LIKE BUT. PETERS FROM OUR
OFFICE WILL BE THE FIRST PERSON
TO SPEAK. OKAY PERFECT SO MISS
PETERS. MORNING CARE MAINTAIN
CHAIRMAN GREAT AND MEMBERS AND
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO SEE THE
HEARINGS I JUST WANT TO CHECK
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE ABLE
TO SEE IN HER EYES WE CAN WE
CAN SEE AND HEAR YOU SO THANK
YOU GREAT I WILL GOOD MORNING
AGAIN I'M JUST COMPUTERS AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I'M IN THIS FIRST PANEL AND
YOU'LL BE HEARING AN OVERVIEW
OF THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
RESPOND TO THE COULD BE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND I AM
GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW AT
THE STATE'S EMERGENCY POWERS
GENERALLY. SOME ISSUES AND
OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS RELATED TO
THE USE OF EMERGENCY POWERS
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. I THINK ABOUT SINCE
MAKE SOME. ABOUT PUTTING
CHANGES TO THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY LIGHTS. FOR THE FIRST
HAVE EXTEND EMERGE APART THE
GOVERNOR HAS BY AUTHORITY TO
DECLARE AND- UNDER VARIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES INCLUDING AN
EPIDEMIC. ONCE AN EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED THE GOVERNOR'S GRANTED
SIGNIFICANT POWERS TO RESPOND
TO THE EMERGENCY TO PROTECT THE
LIVES AND. SAFETY OF PEOPLE AND
PROPERTY IN THE STATE. MANY OF
THESE CAN BE. TO THE DIRECTOR
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE YES.
THESE CARS PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATION WITH MIKE'S
ABILITY NEEDED TO RESPOND
QUICKLY TO EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
EIGHT HOURS PROVIDED DURING AN
EMERGENCY INCLUDE ISSUING AN
IMPROVING. FOR EVERY ELSE WAS
ON THE WAY IF THEY COULD PLEASE
MUTE OR MAKE SURE THEIR MUTED-
THERE'S WE'RE HEARING SOME
RESIDUAL NOISE IN THE
BACKGROUND SO IF YOU COULD DO
THAT PLEASE THANK YOU. PLEASE
CONTINUE SPEAKERS. I WAS THE
MAJOR POWERS THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO THEM INITIATIONDURING AN
EMERGENCY INCLUDE ISSUING AND
ENFORCING EMERGENCY ORDERS AND
REGULATIONS. MMHM SAYS PENDING
EXISTING REGULATIONS ARE LIVE
DIRECTING THE ACTIVITIES OF
STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
REDIRECTING FUNDING WITHIN
DEPARTMENTS AND VARIOUS OTHER
BROAD SPENDING AUTHORITIES THAT
GET THE MINISTRATION ACCESS TO
THE FUNDING NEEDED TO PAY FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACTIVITIES.
AT THE END OF AN EMERGENCY
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUIRED TO PROCLAIM
AN END TO THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY AT THE EARLIEST
POSSIBLE DATE THAT CONDITIONS
WEREN'T. THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
HAS THE POWER TO END AN
EMERGENCY OUT BY A CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. UNLIKE LOCALLY
DECLARED EMERGENCIES IN THE
STATE WHICH EXPIRE
AUTOMATICALLY UNLESS A RATIFIED
BY LOCAL GOVERNING BODY WITHIN
SEVEN DAYS. ARE THERE IS NO
PROVISION FOR AUTOMATIC
EXPIRATION OF THE STATE
DECLARED EMERGENCY. IN THOSE
LOCAL EMERGENCIES AS WELL THE
LOCAL GOVERNING BODY IS GRANTED
THE AUTHORITY TO ANY EMERGENCY
AFTER THEY RATIFIED IT. AND
THEY HVE TO REVIEW THE
EMERGENCY DECLARATION EVERY
SIXTY. I'M JUST IN CONTRAST TO
THE STATE FARM STATEWIDE
EMERGENCY PROCESS. I'M DURING
ITS STATE EMERGENCY R. O. YES
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR COORDINATING
OVERALL EMERGENCY RESPONSE BY
STATE AGENCIES AND COORDINATING
WITH FEDERAL AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND THROUGH THE
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. OTHER STATE
AGENCIES CAN ALSO TAKE A MAJOR
ROLE IN EMERGENCY RESPONSE FOR
EXAMPLE DUE TO THE NATURE OF
THE CALL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OR CD P. H. IS
HEAVILY INVOLVED IN DETERMINING
THE RESPONSE ACTIVITIES THE
STATE WILL TAKE. AND YES
OPERATE THE STATE OPERATIONS
CENTER AND WILL MISSION TSK
DEPARTMENTS OR ASSIGNED
DEPARTMENTS WITH. SPECIFIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
TAKEN. IN ORDER TO FUND THE
COST OF STATE RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES. ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE COORDINATES OVERALL
FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
IN RECENT EMERGENCIES INCLUDING
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES ISSUE
BUDGET LETTERS WHICH ARE
INSTRUCTIONS TO STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
REQUIRING THEM TO REPORT ON ALL
EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES. STATE
AGENCIES THAT REPORT THEIR
EMERGENCY COST APART DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND APARTMENT OF
FINANCE DETERMINES WHETHER
EMERGENCY EXPENDITURES CAN BE
ABSORBED BY THE DEPARTMENT OR
PAID FOR WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES BY REDIRECTING
CERTAIN ACTIVITIES OR WHETHER
DEPARTMENT REQUIRES AN
AUGMENTATION TO ITS OVERALL
BUDGET. WHILE THE MINISTRY HAS
MORE IN FOR AUTHORITY EVERY
OTHER. AND THEY'RE SOMETIMES
COMBINED TOGETHER IN PRACTICE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
FUNNELED EMERGENCY
AUGMENTATIONS. THREE THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT KNOWN INJURY
A LOT. STATE LAW LIMITS THE USE
OF THREE I GENERALLY TO WITHIN
ONE FISCAL YEAR OF THE START OF
AN EMERGENCY. THIS IS BECAUSE
STATE LAW ASSUMES THAT IF AN
EMERGENCY WERE TO SPAN MULTIPLE
YEARS ADMINISTRATION HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PLAN FOR THE SECOND
YEAR OF EMERGENCY RESPONSE
COSTS TO THE STATE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS. DRILL IS
AVAILABLE THIS FISCAL YEAR
UNDER EXISTING LAW WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE TO THE MINISTRATION
NEXT FISCAL YEAR BEGINNING JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
HOWEVER ADMINISTRATION STILL
HAS VERY BROAD SPENDING
AUTHORITIES AVAILABLE TO IT.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT AND THESE WILL
REMAIN AVAILABLE AND TELL THAT.
OF THE EMERGENCY DECLARATION
HAS BEEN ADDED. IN GENERAL
STATE LAW REQUIRES LITTLE IN
THE WAY OF REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE ALLOCATIONS
OF FUNDS FOR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. HOWEVER IT'S COMMON
PRACTICE FOR THE MINISTRATION
TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMATION UPON REQUEST. EVEN
IF IT'S NOT REQUIRED BY STATE
LAW. FOR EXAMPLE THE
MINISTRATION HAS AGREED IN
PREVIOUS HEARINGS TO PROVIDE
UPDATES MONTHLY ON KOBE IT
FISCAL AND SPENDING AND
RESPONSE FUNDING. HOWEVER AT
THIS TIME WE WOULD KNOW THESE
REPORTS HAVE NOT BEEN PROVIDED
MONTHLY BUT IF INCOMING AND-
LESS FREQUENTLY ON A PERIODIC
BASIS. NEXT I WANT TO MOVE TO
ISSUES AND OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
RELATED TO THE OVERALL RESPONSE
TO THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
THE BRIDE EMERGENCY POWERS
GRANTED TO THE GOVERNOR GIVE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO THE MINISTRATION
TO DETERMINE HOW TO RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES. GIVEN THE ONGOING
NATURE OF THE CALL THE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND GIVEN THAT
RESPONDING TO PANDEMICS IS MUCH
LESS COMMON THAN OTHER TYPES OF
EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
UNDERSTANDING THE OVER ARCHING
STRATEGY AND KEY ACTIONS
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING WILL
BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTAND AS
OVERSEAS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE TO THIS EMERGENCY. WE
BEEN TOGETHER SINCE OVERSIGHT.
YOU MAY WANT TO ASK THE
PANELISTS LEADER IN THIS
HEARING OR AT FUTURE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS THIS FALL. ON THOSE
QUESTIONS FIRST ON THE OVERALL
STRATEGY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TAKING ITS ADMINISTRATION
DEVELOPING. AN OVERARCHING PLAN
TO RESPOND TO THE COPING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. A PLAN THAT
WOULD INTEGRATE THE BLUEPRINT
FOR SAFER ECONOMY. WITH EFFORTS
TO EXPAND TESTING CAPACITY AND
ALIGN WITH THE PACE AND SCALE
OF PP OR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT PROCUREMENT. AS WELL
AS OTHER ACTIVITIES. I'M WHAT
WOULD- YESS ROLE BE IN
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING
SUCH A PLAN AND TO THE EXTENT
DEMONSTRATION HOW SUCH A PLAN
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD SHARE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. I'M FOR- YES HOW
ARE THEY BALANCING ON THE
VARIOUS ROLES THEY HAVE TO
MISSION TASK DEPARTMENTS WITH
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES. WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR OVERALL
COORDINATION- AND STRATEGIC
PLANNING OF THEIR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE. LOOKING AT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE
ACTIVITIES HAVE THE COPING
NINETEEN RESPONSE ACTIVITIES
UNDERTAKEN TODAY AND EFFECTIVE.
WHICH STRATEGIES HAVE BEEN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND HOUSE
EFFECTIVENESS BEING MEASURE
HAS- YES IDENTIFIED ANY GAPS IN
THE STATE'S RESPONSE AND WHAT
I'M STEPS ARE BEING TAKEN TO
ADDRESS THOSE GAPS. AND ALSO
INCORPORATING PUBLIC HEALTH
SCIENCES EMERGENCY IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM OUR COMMONS AT
WILDFIRE OTHER TYPE OF
EMERGENCY WHERE THE RESPONSE IS
MAYBE A LITTLE MORE STRAIGHT
FORWARD. ON THIS RESPONSE IS
COMPLEX AND HOW IS- YES I'M
WORKING WITH CD PH TEN
CORPORATION. AND THE
EPIDEMIOLOGICAL DATA INTO THE
STATE'S RESPONSE STRATEGIES.
NEXT I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
ISSUES IN OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES. THIS
STATE HAS VARIOUS EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES THAT GIVE
THE ADMINISTRATION FLEXIBILITY
TO REALLY SEND ANY AVAILABLE
FUNDS TO RESPOND TO AN
EMERGENCY. THESE SPENDING
DECISIONS TAKE PLACE OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE'S THE REGULAR BUDGET
PROCESS AND ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE SAME LEVEL OF LEGISLATIVE
SCRUTINY THAT SPENDING
DECISIONS- ARE WHEN THEY'RE
MADE THROUGH THE BUDGET OR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS THESE. THE
EXPANSIVENESS OF THESE
EMERGENCY SPENDING AUTHORITIES
ALSO RAISES SOME ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. IN
REGARD TO THE OVERSIGHT OF KOBE
NINETEEN AS WELL AS MORE
BROADLY FOR FUTURE EMERGENCIES.
SOME OF THE KEY OVERSIGHT
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE DEVELOPED
INCLUDE OVERALL SPENDING ON
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES IS A
LEGISLATURE SATISFIED WITH HOW
THE SPENDING HAS BEEN
ALLOCATED. SUCH AS BY PROGRAM
AREA TYPE OF ACTIVITY AND THE
GROUPS THAT ARE BEING STARVED.
OUR OH YES AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COORDINATING TO
DETERMINE PRIORITIES FOR
FUNDING AND THE FUNDING LEVELS
TO PRIDE FOR VARIOUS TYPES OF
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES. REGARDING
THE MONTHLY UPDATES
ADMINISTRATION HAS AGREED IN
HEARINGS TO PROVIDE MONTHLY
FISCAL UPDATES ON COVERED
NINETEENTH RESPONSE SPENDING.
THIS INFORMATION IS CRITICAL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE ABLE
TO CONDUCT ITS OVERSIGHT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EMERGENCY
SPENDING AUTHORITIES. AND THEIR
OVERALL RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC. HOWEVER SO FAR THESE
UPDATES HAVE ONLY BEEN PROVIDED
IN MAY AUGUST AND NOVEMBER.
WHAT CHALLENGES AS THE
MINISTRATION FACING WITH
PROVIDING MONTHLY REPORTS AND
HOW CAN THESE CHALLENGES BE
OVERCOMES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CAN PROVIDE REPORTS
MONTHLY AS PROMISED. THEN
LOOKING AT AUGMENTATIONS TO
DEPARTMENTS BUDGET BUDGETS
VERSUS READER ACTIONS HOW IS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DETERMINING WHEN TO PROVIDE
AUGMENTATIONS TO DEPARTMENTS.
VERSES REQUIRING THEM TO
REDIRECT RESOURCES INTERNALLY-
OR ABSORB THOSE COSTS ARE THESE
INTERNAL RE DIRECTIONS OF
RESOURCES BEING TRACKED AND
WILL THIS INFORMATION BE
REPORTED TO THE LEGISLATURE SO
LEGISLATURE. I'M AND THEN ALSO
WITH THE OVERALL FUNDING
AUTHORITY FOR NEXT YEAR AND AS
I SAID THE DRILL AT THIRTY WILL
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR. HOW IS THE
MINISTRATION PLANNING TO FIND
COPING NINETEEN MARGINS THE
RESPONSE IN THE NEXT FISCAL
FISCAL YEAR GIVEN THAT. AND
LASTLY I WANT TO SHARE SOME
COMMENTS REGARDING THE
POTENTIAL LONG TERM CHANGES TO
THE STATE'S EMERGENCY LIFE.
EXISTING EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT RESPUBLIKA
NINETEEN SEVENTY. IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT A SITUATION OF A LENGTHY
ONGOING EMERGENCY. THAT BROADLY
IMPACTS THE ECONOMY AND
EVERYDAY LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
WAS NOT CONTEMPLATED WHEN THE
ACT WAS WRITTEN. THE ONGOING
NATURE OF THE CALL THE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE RESPONSE TO THIS EMERGENCY.
RAISES QUESTIONS AROUND WHETHER
THE STATE'S EMERGENCY LAW
SHOULD BE CHANGED. YOUR STAFF
HAS ASKED US TO PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS ON SUCH POTENTIAL
CHANGES. THERE'S REALLY TWO
BROAD CATEGORIES OF THE TYPES
OF AND CHANGES THAT COULD BE
MADE TO THE STATE'S EMERGENCY
LIGHTS. I'M IN ONE CATEGORY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MAKE CHANGES
TO LIMIT THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES. HOWEVER
THIS WOULD LIKELY LIMIT THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO RESPONDING
NIMBLY TO EMERGENCIES. I NEVER
HAD A GREAT CHANGES THAT COULD
BE CONSIDERED WOULD BE TO
RETAIN HIS BRIDE EMERGENCY
POWERS AND RETAIN
ADMINISTRATION FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES. WHILE
ADDING IN CHECKS AND BALANCES
TO INCREASE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY OF EMERGENCY
DECISION. FOR EXAMPLE REQUIRING
REPORTING ON EMERGENCY SPENDING
WE GET THE LEGISLATURE
INFORMATION NEEDED TO CONDUCT
OVERSIGHT. ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE TO EMERGENCIES. I
WOULD ALSO AVOID CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
REQUESTED INFORMATION BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT PROVIDING
IT IN A TIMELY MANNER. OTHER
CHANGES COULD INCLUDE REQUIRING
ADMINISTRATION TO INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE OF PLANNED
ACTIVITIES BEFORE FUNDS ARE
SPENT. OR PLACING LIMITS ON
TOTAL SPENDING TO ENSURE THAT
THE TOTAL SPENDING ON
EMERGENCIES DOES NOT HAVE
OVERALL BUDGETARY IMPACTS THAT
COULD UNDERMINE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS I AM HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME OR TURN
THINGS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE-
AND HOLLINGSHEAD WHO HAS A
PRESENTATION ON THE OVERALL
FUNDING- PROVIDED FOR COVERS.
MISTER TERRY I'M SORRY BUT WE
ARE UNABLE TO HEAR YOU SO WE
ARE UNCLEAR WHETHER YOU'RE
ASKING US QUESTIONS OR WHETHER
YOU WANT THEM TO MAKE HER
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU. OKAY I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MISS
HOLLINGSHEAD AND THEY WILL-
AFTER WHAT THE PANEL'S SPEAKING
THE WATER. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND HAULING
SAID AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I MEAN TO BE
SPEAKING TO YOU TODAY FOR MY
HAND OUT AND THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE FOLLOWING
ALONG AT HOME. YOU CAN FIND IT
ON THE L. A. O. DOT CA DOC OF.
SO JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON MY
COLLEAGUES COMENTS ABOUT
AUTHORITY I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT.
WILL BE NINETEEN SPENDING. VERY
BROADLY IN THE STATE BY BOTH
THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THIS IS GOING
TO BE VERY HIGH LEVEL AND
HOPEFULLY PRETTY QUICK BUT- I
WILL FOCUS. A LITTLE BIT ON.
THE AUTHORITY OF THE SOURCES OF
AUTHORITY FOR VARIOUS. PARTS OF
SPENDING. SO THIS WILL BE
DIVIDED INTO THREE PARTS SELLS
TALK FIRST ABOUT THE FUNDS
SOURCE M. AND FOCUS THEIR OWN
AUTHORITY THEN I'LL TALK ABOUT
THE PURPOSE FOR WHICH THE FUNDS
ARE BEING SPENT. AND THEN I
FINALLY CONCLUDED WITH PROGRAM
AREA. SO ON THE FIRST PAGE OF
THE HANDOUT. UP FRONT SOURCES
RECALLED IN NINETEEN RELATED
SPENDING SO AS YOU CAN SEE IN
THIS. THAT FIGURE AT THE BY FAR
THE LARGEST SINGLE AMOUNT THAT
HAS BEEN SPENT ON PUBLIC
NINETEEN BY EITHER THE STATE OR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. IS FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
THESE ARE THE BENEFIT
ENHANCEMENTS THAT WERE PASSED
AS PART OF THE CARE IS ACTIVE
AND THEN LATER PERSONALLY
EXTENDED UNDER EXECUTIVE
ACTION- BUT ESSENTIALLY
PROVIDED MORE BENEFITS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY ELIGIBLE
TO YOU FOR YOU WHY. AND THEN
ALSO EXTENDED YOU ARE TWO
PEOPLE WHO WERE PREVIOUSLY
INELIGIBLE INCLUDING THE SELF
EMPLOYED. THE STATE REALLY DOES
NOT HAVE. A ROLE IN DETERMINING
HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED-
THE STATE IS REALLY JUST KIND
OF A PASSED THROUGH FOR THOSE
FUNDS AND THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
INCLUDED HERE. BUT FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE GRAPHIC THIS
STATE HAS VARYING DEGREES OF
AUTHORITY AND ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
BEING SPENT AND THE LEGISLATURE
IN PARTICULAR- HAS SORT OF
DIFFERENT ROLES DEPENDING ON
WHICH PART OF MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DESPITE THE FACT
THAT. EVEN WHEN WE FOCUS ON THE
REMAINING IECES. THIS IS
REALLY AGAIN MOSTLY AN
OVERWHELMINGLY. MAJORITY
FEDERAL MONEY. SO JUST GIVE A
CALL OF EGGS THE- RELIEF I ARE
C. ALFA. WELL PASSED AS PART OF
THE CARE IS ACTIVE PROVIDED
NINE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
TO THE STATE. AND ON THE
LEGISLATURE DID ALLOCATE SIERRA
THREE WOULD BE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PROCESS. BUT
THERE WAS ALSO CONTROL SECTION
LANGUAGE THAT WAS PROVIDED AS
PART OF THAT ALLOCATION
ALLOWING THE ADMINISTRATION TO
RE DIRECT- GOT FUNDING IF IT
WAS CLEAR THAT IT WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO BE SPENT BY THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR WHICH IS THE
DEADLINE. FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SET FOR AND SPENDING
CRF MONEY. ANOTHER IS SORT OF-
IMPORTANT EXAMPLE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT A THIRTY ON THE ROLE OF
THE STATE LEGISLATURE. AND THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH IS THE STATE
FUNDING PIECE AND THIS IS THE
PIECE THAT SEAN AND BROWN. AN
IMPORTANT NOTE BEFORE I TALK
ABOUT A THIRTY IS THAT. THAT
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S LIFE THERE
IS ABOUT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THE ACTUAL STATE GENERAL
FUND IMPLICATION OF THAT IS
GOING TO BE. PERHAPS A QUARTER
OF THAT AMOUNT AND THE REASON
THAT IT'S- THAT IT'S LOWER IS
THAT THE STATE WILL EVENTUALLY
BE. REIMBURSED ABOUT 75% BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR THESE
OUTLAYS BUT- THEY ARE STATE
DIRECTED AND- THE STATE HAS.
SORT OF A LOT OF DISCUSSION AND
HOW TO SPEND THIS MONEY. SO
THIS THIS FUNDING HAS REALLY
BEEN ALLOCATED IN A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT- PRIMARILY
THROUGH- THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH'S
DISASTER AND EMERGENCY
AUTHORITIES THAT MY COLLEAGUE
WAS SPEAKING TO EARLIER IN
PARTICULAR- THE DISASTER
RESPONSE IN EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS A COUNTER JURY A LOT.
TURNING TO THE NEXT PAGE. THIS
GRAPHIC OR OR SET OF GRAPHICS
SHOWS NINETEEN SPENDING BY
PROFESSOR BY TYPE AND WE'VE
DIVIDED IT INTO SIX DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THE LARGEST YOU
SHOWN IN ORANGE AND THEN IN
THIS SORT OF SEAFOAM GREEN ARE
CONTROLLING THE SPREAD OF
CORPORATE NINETEEN WHICH IS
ACTIVITIES LIKE MASK
PROCUREMENT TESTING AND CONTACT
TRACING ARE CONTROLLING THE
SPREAD AND THEN FACILITATE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING WHICH ARE
OF COURSE RELATED ACTIVITIES
BUT THE SUPPORTS THAT ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS TO. STAY AT HOME OR
OTHERWISE ISOLATED FROM OTHER
PEOPLE AND THAT INCLUDES
ACTIVITIES LIKE DISTANCE
LEARNING FOR STUDENTS-
ACQUIRING HOTEL AND MOTEL BEDS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. THE TOP OF THE
FIGURE IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
FIGURE SHOWING THE SAME DATA.
BUT THE TOP IS DESTROYING THE
PROPORTION FOR EACH ONE OF
THOSE CATEGORIES AND THEN THE
BOTTOM IS SHOWING- SORT OF
SINGLE EXPENDITURE AMOUNTS
WITHIN EACH. AND AS YOU CAN SEE
SOME OF THE LARGER AMOUNTS
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE MONEY
THAT'S GOING TO SCHOOLS TO
FACILITATE OUR DISTANCE
LEARNING. OR PURCHASES OF PPP
AND PROCUREMENT OF OTHER OF
OTHER MEDICAL SUPPLIES. STE AND
THEN TO THE FINAL PAGE THIS IS
SIMILAR AT THE SAME PER BASIS
OF DATA BUT BUT PROVIDED WITH
THAT KIND OF DIFFERENT HI SO
THIS IS SHOWING YOU BY PROGRAM
AREA AND THEN BY THE SIX
DIFFERENT- CATEGORIES THAT I
THAT I HATE TO SPOKE ABOUT ON
THE LAST PAGE SO AND THE
LARGEST SINGLE PROGRAM AREA IN
WHICH I THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ARE SPENDING MONEY
pCOURSE HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
MONEY IS GOING TO CONTROL THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. AND THEN
THE SECOND LARGEST CATEGORY IS
FOR EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE
AND MOST OF THAT MONEY IS GOING
TO FACILITATE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING AND IN AND IN
PARTICULAR THAT'S FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING. SO WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
pPERFORMANCE AND THE MISTER BASS.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
THERESA KALRA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE STEVEN BENSON TO
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE OUR LATEST
FISCAL INFORMATION RELATED TO
KOBE IN NINETEEN AND TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE- I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF TO ALLOW TIME
FOR QUESTIONS AND AT THE END OF
THIS PANEL- AND IN SOME IN AN
EFFORT TO CONTINUE PROMOTING
TRANSPARENCY IN PROVIDING
REGULAR UPDATES POST BUDGET
ACT. SAID DEPARTMENT FINANCES
RELEASED IN THE US- BOTH
RELEASED AN UPDATE IN AUGUST
AND HAS JUST RELEASED ITS
NOVEMBER FISCAL UPDATE THAT
PROVIDES UPDATED FISCAL DETAIL
AND INFORMATION RELATED TO
EXPENDITURES IN VARIOUS PROGRAM
CATEGORIES RELATED TO COPE IN
NINETEEN- IN ADDITION IN
SEPTEMBER FINANCE ALSO PROVIDED
AN UPDATE. ON FEDERAL FUNDING.
AT A FINANCE EARLY ESTIMATES.
COMBINED TOTAL COSTS PRESIDENT
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FISCAL YEARS APPROXIMATELY NINE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
WITH A CURRENTLY ESTIMATED THAT
GENERAL FUND IMPACT OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
BILLION. AT A HIGH LEVEL
COMPARED TO THE AUGUST
ESTIMATES THE TO YOUR COSTS ARE
PROJECTED TO INCREASE BY
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION- THERE ARE TWO AT
EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES WE
HIGHLIGHT AS AS CONTRIBUTING
TO. THIS INCREASED ON THE FIRST
OF THE STATE LABORATORY
TESTING. LABORATORY TESTING
ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT A TWO POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE FOR
VARIOUS TESTING EXPENDITURES
I'M INCLUDING THE NEW IN STATE
LABORATORY. CAPACITY THAT WILL
EXPAND TO TESTING AVAILABLE IN
THE STATE. IN ADDITION
CONSISTENT WITH FUNDING
PROVIDED AND- SB ONE FIFTEEN AN
AMENDMENT TO THE BUDGET ACT-
NOVEMBER COST ESTIMATE INCLUDES
A LITTLE OVER SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND- GENERAL FUND FOR
OUTREACH FOCUSED ON COMMUNITIES
AND ECONOMIC SECTORS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE VIRUS AS WELL AS FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. M. AS ANOTHER POINT
OF COMPARISON AND THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET REFLECTED A TOTAL
OF EIGHT POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT EMERGENCY
RESPONSE COSTS ACROSS THE SAME
FISCAL YEAR SO- AS COMPARED
FROM BUDGET ACT IN NOVEMBER
IT'S AN INCREASE OF ABOUT ONE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS. AND
WE HAVE. ADDITIONAL COLLEAGUES
HERE AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS
AND FROM THE COMMITTEE AND- ARE
AVAILABLE. AT THE END OF THE
PANEL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON. AND MR BENSON'S
HERE FOR THAT THE QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS THAT I AM. VERY GOOD
THEN WE'RE GOING TO CHIU THIRTY
DIRECTOR CURRY.
IF FIVE CHIEF
TO BE DIRECTOR CURRY COULD
START SPEAKING- PERHAPS YOUR
VIEW LOOKING ALL. YOU CAN WE
SEE YOU. MISTER GREENE YES IF
YOU COULD JUST START ALKING
YOU'RE OKAY I THINK WE'VE GOT
THAT WORKING. EXCELLENT WELL
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON'S IN
GRAY AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANTED TO
SAY HOW MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU AN
UPDATE ON CALLOW YESS ROLE IN
OUR SUPPORT. FOR THE
OPERATIONAL EFFORTS TO RESPOND
TO THIS ONGOING PANDEMIC I
DON'T THINK I COULD SAY IT.
BETTER THAN EITHER OF YOU TWO
DID IN THE FACT THAT WERE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS- ARE
MANAGING YOU KNOW SOMETHING
JUST UNPRECEDENTED AND ONGOING
AND OUR VIGILANCE AND ON OUR
NEED TO STAY CONNECTED AND I
KEEP THAT THE RESPONSE- GOING
IS. SOMETHING THAT'S OF COURSE
A TOP PRIORITY FOR OUR OFFICE
AND FOR THE STATE AND SINCE
EARLY IN TWENTY TWENTY WE BEGAN
THIS YOU KNOW REALLY BACK TO
JANUARY AND SO AND- THEN SUING
MONTHS WE PLAYED A DIRECT ROLE
IN COORDINATING THE STATE'S
RESPONSE. IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE'S HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND MANY MANY OTHER
STATE AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN
AT THE TABLE AS AS WE'VE
CONTENDED WITH THIS RESPONSE IN
THE MONTHS THAT HAVE ENSUED.
THIS IS BEEN DONE FOR A SYSTEM
THAT WERE ACCUSTOMED TO OR
CUSTOM TO USING IT FOR OTHER
DISASTERS AND EMERGENCIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA EVERYTHING
RANGING FROM THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED EARLIER.
TO SPECIALIZED TASK FORCES TO
TACKLE- YOU KNOW HIGHLY COMPLEX
AND TECHNICAL ISSUES AND AS
WELL AS A UNIFIED COORDINATION
GROUP AND THAT'S WHERE THE
CABINET AGENCIES COME TOGETHER
AND CONVENE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR EFFORTS ARE ALIGNED. OUR
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER HAS
BEEN ACTIVATED FOR THIS EVENT
FOR OVER TWO HUNDRED DAYS NOW-
IT IS NOT AND THE LONGEST
ACTIVATION WE'VE HAD AS YOU
MENTIONED SHERMAN TAKING THAT
THE STATE DROUGHT WENT ON FOR
YEARS. BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
UNPRECEDENTED IN MANY WAYS AND
I CERTAINLY REQUIRED US TO BE
AT A LEVEL OF RESPONSE THAT IS
A UNIQUE FOR SOMETHING THAT'S
OF THIS DURATION IT'S ALSO A
LAYERED SYSTEM SO WE HAVE
EVERYTHING FROM TACTICAL
OPERATIONS WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WORKING DAY IN AND DAY OUT. AT
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL ORGANIZING
IN THE RESPONSE. WHAT THE NEEDS
ARE. ALL THE WAY UP TO THE
STRATEGIC LEVEL WITH THE
DECISION MAKERS IN THE
LEADERSHIP OF WORKING TOGETHER
TO. DRIVE PRIORITIES AND- ND
ENSURE THAT OUR RESPONSES
EFFECTIVE. OUR OFFICE HAS A
UNIQUE ROLE OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THE DIFFERENT CAPABILITIES
ARE ACROSS THE STATE GOVERNMENT
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES-
SOMETHING WERE AGAIN A CUSTOM
TO BECAUSE OF THE DIFFERENT
HAZARDS THAT WE FACE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND THAT WE MANAGE
ALL THE TIME- AND WE DEPLOY
THOSE CAPABILITIES TO PROBLEM
SOLVING AND TO MEET NEEDS IN
THE TIME OF EMERGENCY DOES IT
DISASTERS. THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE EMERGENCY PLAN
THE STATE EMERGENCY PLAN IS
WHAT OUTLINES. THE EMERGENCY
ORGANIZATION AND CALIFORNIA THE
PROCESSES THAT WE USE AND THE
ROLES OF STATE GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. BUT AT THE SAME TIME
IT'S A FLEXIBLE SYSTEM AND I
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT AS WE
TALK A LITTLE BIT LATER WITH
ABOUT. ABOUT THE VACCINE
PLANNING AND HOW THAT IS KIND
OF RISING UP TO BE AT NEW AREA
FOCUS JUST AS IMPORTANT AS ALL%
THE OTHER AREAS. AS A FOCUS AND
AT THE SAME TIME AS CASES
ARISING IN CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
GONNA BE CALLED BALANCING THE
EFFORTS OF VACCINE PLANNING AND
RESPONSE PERHAPS TO IN. IT NO
NOT PERHAPS BUT TO INCREASE
CASE RISING AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT MIGHT ENSUE. WITH THE
RESPONSE TO THOSE THINGS AND
ALL THAT HAPPENS IN PARALLEL-
JUST AREA THE FOCUS THAT WE'VE
CORD ENDED THIS IS BY NOT NOT
NOT AT ALL MEANS NON EXHAUSTIVE
LIST BUT THINGS LIKE MEDICAL
SURGE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
ARE PEOPLE EQUIPMENT
FACILITIES. AVAILABLE TO HELP
OUR HOSPITAL SYSTEMS A MEDICAL
PROVIDERS. TO PROVIDE. CARE TO
PEOPLE WITH THE COVERED
NINETEEN ENFORCEMENT- THAT IS
THERE'S BEEN OVER ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION CONTACTS MADE IN
THE STATE FAMILY HAS COME
TOGETHER- WITH EVERY AGENCY WHO
AS A PART OF THIS TO NOT JUST
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO TO.
LEVERAGE THEIR EFFORTS IN
UNITY- TO PROVIDE ENFORCEMENT
HOUSING AND SOCIAL SERVICES I
THINK IT'S BEEN TOUCHED AND
ALREADY MANY MANY. TYPES. OF
PROGRAMS INCLUDING FOR HOMELESS.
ON HEALTH WORKER SAID THAT THEY
HAVE A SAFE AND SECURE. HOUSING
AS THEY UNDERTAKE THIS
TREMENDOUS JOB- AGRICULTURAL
WORKFORCE AT CENTER ALL OF THAT
TO EMPLOY. SAFETY MEASURES SO
THAT WE ARE PREVENTING THE
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE AND
MAKING SURE THAT OUR CENTRAL.
SERVICES CONTINUE. EMERGENCY
FEEDING- ANOTHER AREA- FOOD
BANK SUPPORT AT PROGRAMS LIKE
GREAT PLATES WHERE THERE'S BEEN
OVER FIFTEEN MILLION MEALS
SERVED. TO A CALIFORNIANS AND
THAT MANY CITIES AND COUNTIES
PARTICIPATING. AND THEN
GEOGRAPHIC BASED EFFORT TO
WE'VE HAD MORE REAP OF LEAN DEN
IF YOU WILL IN CERTAIN
GEOGRAPHIC AREAS WHERE THEY HAD
VERY SPECIALIZED NEEDS CENTRAL
VALLEY IS AN EXAMPLE IMPERIAL
COUNTY- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND AGAIN THAT'S BOTH T MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE COMMUNITIES
HAVE THE FULL. COORDINATED
COHESIVE STATE SUPPORT BOTH ON
THE PREVENTION SIDE AND TESTING
CONTACT TRACING BUT ALSO ON THE
RESPONSE SIDE. WITH THAT HELP
WITH THEIR WITH THEIR MEDICAL
RESPONSE NEEDS. AND THEN OF
COURSE- IN A SECOND NEXT PANEL
YOU'RE WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS
LOGISTICS AND COMMODITY
MOVEMENT IT'S BEEN A MASSIVE
EFFORT- FIVE HUNDRED MILLION I
THINK I'M- JUST IN THE LPP.
MASS CATEGORY ALONE HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED SO FAR. SO IN
ADDITION TO THE OPERATIONAL
COORDINATION THE STATE PARTNERS
OF ALSO ALIGNED IMPORTANTLY
AROUND PUBLIC INFORMATION AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION SO THAT WE
HAVE REALLY A ONE STOP SHOP.
FOR THE PUBLIC FOR DECISION
MAKERS- AND ALL IT EVERYTHING
IN BETWEEN TO SEE THAT YOUR
DASHBOARDS AND DATA AND
INFORMATION ABOUT CASE RATES SO
THAT- SO THAT THAT. IS IT IS IN
A COHESIVE AND COORDINATED- YOU
KNOW ONE PLACE FOR- FOR ALL THE
THINGS THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR AND
I THINK THAT HAS BEEN AND YOU
KNOW JUST A- JUST A TREMENDOUS
EFFORT ACROSS STATE FAMILIES
NOT IT NOT UNLIKE WHAT WE DO
WITH OTHER TYPES OF DISASTERS
WHERE WE HAVE REALLY ONE VOICE
TO THE PUBLIC. AND EVERYBODY'S
ON AT UC COLLATING THEIR
INFORMATION TOGETHER AND
PRESENTING IT IN A UNIFIED
FRONT. WERE ALSO RESPONSIBLE
FOR PART OF THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE PART JUST LIKE IN
RECOVERY FROM OTHER DISASTERS
WE THINK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE-FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY. NOT ONLY TO GET FEDERAL
RESOURCES FOR RESPONSE BUT ALSO
ON THE FINANCIAL PIECE SO-
CALLAWAY AS AS AS IT HAS AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE A STRONG
ROLE IN. WORKING WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE LEVERAGING THOSE
PROGRAMS- IT TO THE EXTENT-POSSIBLE WE'VE DONE THAT WITH
THE FEMA PROGRAMS IN WAYS WE'VE
NEVER DONE BEFORE. AND
COLLUDING SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT I MENTIONED EARLIER FOR
FEEDING AND HOUSING AND- YOU
KNOW ALWAYS CONSTANTLY WORKING
THROUGH TO SEE- BUT WE CAN-
EMPLOY IN TERMS OF THE BRINGING
IN THE FEDERAL ASSISTANCE TO
CALIFORNIA THROUGH FEET FOR
FEMA. AND THEN IN THE MIDST OF
COVERED- AS WAS AS IT HAPPENS
IN CALIFORNIA WE MANAGED A
HISTORIC FIRE SEASON. THAT IS
NOT OVER YET SO FAR JUST TO
DATE FOR OVER FOUR MILLION
ACRES BURNED- TRAGICALLY DIED
NEARING TEN THOUSAND STRUCTURES
DESTROYED THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND TWENTY SEVEN. OVER FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES UNDER A FEDERAL
DISASTER DECLARATION FOR
WILDFIRE SO WHILE WE'RE CORD
CONTINUING TO COORDINATE THE CO
OF IN RESPONSE. YEAH I EVENTS
THAT HAVE OCCURRED THE WE ARE
ALSO MANAGING THE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY FOR THESE WILDFIRES
AND ARE ACTIVELY WORKING NOW
ON. HELPING THOSE COMMUNITIES-
START THE JOURNEY TO RECOVERY-
RAPIDLY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE- YOU KNOW GETTING
BACK. ON THEIR FEET AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE INCLUDING DEBRIS
OPERATIONS ARE LOOKING OUT FOR
WATERSHED IMPACTS FROM THESE
FIRES AND HOW WE MIGHT RESPOND
TO THOSE AS WELL AS EMERGENCY
HOUSING RELATED TO THE
WILDFIRES. SO ALL OF THAT'S
HAPPENING AND IN CONCERT WITH
ONE ANOTHER- BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE
SEEING CASES RISE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO- WE HAVE THE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE WE DEVELOP TO
A LOT OF THINGS IN THE IN THE
EARLY DAYS OF THIS PANDEMIC IN
THE MONTHS AND WE'RE GOING TO
BE LEVERAGING THOSE SAME TOOLS
AND RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN QUICKLY MOBILIZE.
ANTICIPATE WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
GOING TO BE AND RESPOND TO
EMERGENCY NEEDS GOING FORWARD.
THE LATEST EFFORT WE'RE GOING
TO DISCUSS IN A LITTLE BIT IS
VACCINE PLANNING AND AS I
MENTIONED WE'RE GOING TO- YOU
KNOW HAVE THAT EFFORT FILLED IN
WITH THE OVERALL STATE
RESPONSE. AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE BEING EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
WITH LEVERAGING OUR STATE
RESOURCES TO. EFFECTIVELY PLAN
FOR AND CARRY THAT OUT THAT
IMPORTANT CRITICAL MISSION FOR
CALIFORNIA. EVERY DISASTER
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN AND ADJUST AND WE'RE
DOING THAT IN REAL TIME IN THIS
IN THIS EVENT. AND CONTINUE TO
APPROVE IMPROVE FOR WHAT COMES
NEXT. WILL REMAIN VIGILANT AND
RESPONSIVE IMPORTANTLY OUR
STATE AGENCIES WILL REMAIN A
COHESIVE ORGANIZATION TO
CONTINUE SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER.
AND OUR HEALTH CARE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND OF COURSE
OUR- CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES WHO
CONTENDED WITH SO MUCH ALREADY
IN TWENTY TWENTY. SO I'LL STOP
THERE ON THE ON THE OVERVIEW OF
OPERATIONS I KNOW THAT WE'R
GONNA. TALK ABOUT VACCINE
PLANNING AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AT THE END AND ALSO
COMMENT ON CALABASAS. ROLE IN
THAT VACCINE PLANNING. THANK
YOU WILL NOW GO TO THE CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE ONLY.
IF YOU COULD. SHE'S ON THE
PHONE YEAH SHE COULD JUST START
TALKING I THINK IT SHOULD GO TO.
CHIEF TO BE DIRECTED PEOPLE TO
START TALKING IF YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE THAT'S FINE. THE LINE OF
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR HAS
DROPPED FROM THE CALL WE ARE
WAITING ON A CALL BACK. ONE ONE
AFTER QUESTIONS. WE'RE WAITING
FOR CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
ELLIE WHY DON'T WE USE THE TIME
FOR SOME QUESTIONS. THE MYSTERY
HAVE QUESTIONS WAS STRICTER
THAN MR BLOOD. RESTAURANT. ALL
BEGIN WITH CODE THE GENERAL
QUESTION DIRECTED THE PANELISTS.
IS ANYONE DISAGREE WITH THE
STATEMENT THAT DURING STATE
FEDERAL EMERGENCIES EVERY
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE
ABSOLUTE CONFIDENCE THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS ACTING NOT
POLITICALLY BUT TO THE NEEDS OF
EACH AND EVERY CALIFORNIA THAT
A FAIR STATEMENT. TELL. I'LL
TAKE THE SILENCE THAT
EVERYONE'S IN AGREEMENT. I WANT
TO DIG INTO. I GUESS COMMITTEE
EQUITY. OF THE FEDERAL- CARES
ACT FUNDING HOW THAT'S BEEN
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE CAN ANYONE ON
THE PANEL. TELL ME WITH
CERTAINTY- HOW MUCH MONEY
ACROSS ALL THESE DIFFERENT
PARTS HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO
EACH COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE. IS
THAT IS THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE. ALL ASK THE L. A. L.
TO THE INFORMATION FOLKS. S.
THANK YOU AND MISTER GRAY WE-
DO NOT HAVE THAT DATA IN FRONT
OF US I THINK THERE'S SOME SORT
OF SPECIFIC POTS OF MONEY
WITHIN THAT TOTAL YOU KNOW
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLAR UNIVERSE THAT COULD BE
EXAMINED IN THAT WAY BUT WE
DON'T HAVE FIGURES FOR EVERY
SINGLE COMPONENT OF IT. SO
COULD WE IT WILL BE THE TIME
FRAME TO GET A BREAK DOWN TO MY
OFFICE OR IN FRONT OF THE
MEMBERS IS COMMITTEE. ON A
COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS. TOTAL.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THEIR STOCK ON THAT- FOR SOME
OF THE FIGURES IT COULD BE
RELATIVELY QUICKLY PROBABLY
ALREADY HOT NUMBERS- AND BUT
FOR OTHER PIECES OF THE PIE IT
MAY BE- MUCH MORE TIME
CONSUMING OR IN FCT IS NOT
AVAILABLE WHAT APPRECIATE LEAST
TAKING THE WHAT IS AVAILABLE
TELLING IT UP ON A COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS AND GET THAT
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE-
AND- TO THE MEMBERS HERE TODAY-
HOW MUCH MONEY WAS DIRECTLY
ALLOCATED TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO THE CARE
SECTOR. ALL SPECIFICALLY ASSET
OF THE OHIO. FINANCE I THINK
THEY PROBABLY HAVE THE FIGURES
IN FRONT OF THEM. GOOD MORNING
AT CHRISTEN CERTAIN DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT HAVE POPULATIONS
ABOVE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND OR
FIVE HUNDRED. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION RECEIVED- FIVE POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS IN TOTAL.
OKAY AND HOW MUCH MONEY WAS.
DIRECTED TO THE STATE FOR AS
KIND OF A PASTOR ALLOCATION TO
STATE NEEDS. THE STATE RECEIVED
NINE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT AMOUNT WE
PASSED THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT
WERE BELOW THE POPULATION
THRESHOLD. SET BY THE US
TREASURY SO IF I HEARD YOU
CORRECTLY THE TWENTY TWO
JURISDICTIONS IN THIS STATE
CITIES AND COUNTIES ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND RECEIVE SOMEWHERE IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF ALMOST SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. THE STATE
RECEIVED ALMOST TEN BILLION AND
I'VE THAT PASSED AROUND TWO
BILLION TO SMALLER TOWNS AND
CITIES IS THAT. REASONABLY
ACCURATE. AT THAT THAT IS
CERTAINLY BETTER CERTAINLY ONE
COMPONENT OF THE PASTORS TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WE ALSO
DIRECTED AT ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. TO DATE
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS- WHICH IS
A VERY HIGH RISK POPULATION IN
RELATIONSHIP TO PREVENT AND WE
HAVE FOUR POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY. SO THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE STATE FUNDS WENT TO
JURISDICTIONS OF A LOCAL LEVEL.
OKAY BUT- IT WOULD BE FAIR TO
POINT OUT THAT. SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS GOT A PORTION OF
THE NIGHT AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. ALONG WITH WHATEVER
PORTIONS THAT MONEY WENT TO
STATEWIDE INTERESTS. WILD
LARGER JURISDICTIONS GOT THAT
SAME BENEFIT FROM NINE HALF
BILLION AND ADDITIONALLY AN
ADDITIONAL SIX OR FIVE POINT
SIX OR FIVE POINT EIGHT I CAN
CALL THE NUMBER YOU CITED ON IT
CERTAINLY AT FIRST BLUSH WOULD
STRIKE THIS MEMBER OF THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT WE DIDN'T
NECESSARILY ACTED WE DISTRIBUTE
THIS MONEY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THAT PERHAPS SOME RURAL
JURISDICTIONS WERE IN THE
POSITION TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR CONSTITUENTS OR CERTAINLY
AT THE- DISCRETION OF WHETHER
NOT THE STATE WAS GOING TO PASS
FUNDS DOWN THROUGH THEM- IF
THEY ASKED FOR REIMBURSEMENT OF
CERTAIN THINGS WHILE. LARGER
JURISDICTIONS. WERE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR OWN
FUNDING. THAT IS ANY PART OF
WHAT I JUST SAID AND UNFAIR
STATEMENT. D. B. DISTRIBUTION
FAR LOCAL ENTITIES WAS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. AND WE FEEL THAT IT
IS A VERY EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION BASED ON THE
CONCENTRATION OF PUBLIC PLACES.
IN OUR LARGEST POPULATION
CENTERS. THAT WAS BASED ON THE
DATA AT THAT TIME INTERESTING
SO. TO FINANCE THIS
ADMINISTRATION USE ANY EQUITY
METRICS TO TARGET THOSE FUNDS
TO AREAS OF THE STATE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
UNEMPLOYED OR PEOPLE LIVING IN
POVERTY. THAT WOULD NOT BE
ALLOCATION FORMULA THAT WAS
AGREED UPON WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THERE ARE
CERTAINLY OTHER AREAS OF
FUNDING THAT CAN HELP AND KIND
OF ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE HIGH
NEED. AND WE DID SO IN SOME OF
THE CDC FUNDING THAT WAS
ALLOCATED TO LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH STATISTICS. M. PURSUANT
TO THE- FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
WAS AVAILABLE. ONE LET ME DRILL
DOWN FURTHER DID WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT IN ANY OF OUR METRICS
THE DEGREE TO WHICH A WORK%
FORCE IN ANY PARTICULAR
JURISDICTION IS CONSIDERED.
ESSENTIAL SUCH AS- IN MY
DISTRICT- MY COLLEAGUE CECILY
ARE ENCOURAGED DISTRICT WE HAVE
A LOT OF AGRICULTURIST BY
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER
AGRICULTURE WORKERS WHO HAD TO
CONTINUE TO FEED THE STATE
DURING THIS. ACADEMIC THIS
EPIDEMIC AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER RANDALL FROM
FRESNO APPRECIATES THAT ASPECT
OF WHAT'S GOING ON HERE TOO AND
I'LL TELL YOU. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE REPRESENTING A
ROLLER COASTER COMMUNITY I'VE
HAD SOME COLLEAGUES. IN THIS
INSTITUTION WHO HAVE TAKEN THE
TIME TO PONTIFICATE. AND BE
ACCUSATORY. AND YET THEY DIDN'T
SEND ANY OTHER P. P. FROM SAN
DIEGO THEY DIDN'T SEND ANY
THEIR MONEY FROM SAID. SO THIS
IS AN ISSUE I REALLY FEEL
STRONGLY ABOUT IN RETROSPECT
THAT WE MAKE SURE GOING FORWARD
IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS THAT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN CAN HAVE
CONFIDENCE. NOT THAT THE STATE
GOVERNMENT WILL THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS OR THE
ADMINISTRATION- PAST MONEY DOWN
TO THEM BUT RATHER HAVE SOME
MONEY TO DEAL AND ADDRESS
SERIOUS ISSUES HAPPENING AT
HOME BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW WE GET
A PASTOR SITUATIONS THERE ARE
DELAYS THERE ARE COMPLICATIONS
THERE IS BUREAUCRACY. AND
HOPEFULLY WHEN ELLIE- GETS US
SOME INFORMATION ON OR AT LEAST
THE BEST INFORMATION WE HAVE OF
HOW EQUITABLE THESE FUNDS HAVE
BEEN. WE CAN DEVELOP AUTOMATION
SOME METRICS GOING FORWARD THEY
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE TREATED.
FAIRLY AS FUNDING GOES BECAUSE
WE ALL KNOW NOT BEING PREPARED
GOING INTO DISASTERS WHEN-
WE'RE MAKING IT UP AS WE GO
AND- THAT'SWHEN POLITICS%
INSERTS ITS UGLY HEAD INTO
POLICY AND WE END UP WITH. THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE TO
HAVE THE LARGEST POLITICAL
POWER- GETTING THE LION'S SHARE
THE RESOURCES ALL LIVE. IN MY
TIME THAT THE COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND PASS IT ON TO THE
NEXT MEMBER. THANKS MISTER
MONTE. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I HAD A QUESTION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND.
THERE HAS BEEN YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY OVER THE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS A LOT OF FRUSTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE LACK OF
LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT IN
DECIDING HOW THESE OF FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED AND- IN
PARTICIPATING IN THE STATE'S
RESPONSE. M. A. R. I THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE WAS VERY CLEAR
WHEN WE PASSED SB EIGHTY NINE A
FEW MONTHS AGO. THE DELEGATION
OF AUTHORITY THAT WE WERE
GIVING TO THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
THERE WERE CERTAIN KINDS OF IS
THE SPENDING AUTHORITY THAT WE
RECOGNIZE LEGISLATIVE PRINT THE
THERE ARE OTHER KINDS OF
RESPONSE FUNDING THAT WE WANTED
TO BE A PART OF IT
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. IS REALLY NOT GIVEN
THE LEGISLATURE THAT ROLE I
MEAN WE'VE GOT A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT. THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH HAS BEEN REPORTING THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN SPENDING
DECISIONS ARE MADE BUT NOT
INVOLVING THE LEGISLATURE IN
MAKING THOSE SPENDING DECISIONS
SO THE L. A. ALWAYS LAID OUT
SOME PRETTY STARK. OPTIONS FOR
US WE COULD- WE COULD PASS A
RESOLUTION TO END THE
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY THAT
WOULD BE ONE THING WE COULD DO
PRETTY DRACONIAN- WE COULD
CHANGE STATE LAW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN
IN THE FUTURE EMERGENCY- BUT
I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. THE
DELEGATION OF AUTHORITY RIGHT
NOW AND SO MY QUESTION FOR THE
DELAY OFFICE DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHY WE ARE SO FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THIS AND WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO TO
BE MORE OF A PARTNER WITH YOU.
IN MAKING SPENDING DECISIONS.
ACTRESS HEATHER OR DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AGAIN. AND WE HAVE BEEN
REPORTING AND PROVIDING
NOTIFICATION LETTERS AS NOTED
CONSISTENT WITH EXISTING LAW
WE'VE ALSO BEEN PROVIDING
FISCAL UPDATES- AS FAR BACK AS
WHEN CONTROL SECTIONS OF. THIS
WAS IN PLACE AND BEEN TRYING TO
AGAIN PROVIDE AS- THE
TRANSPARENCY OF INFORMATION
BOTH FOR THE STATE EXPENDITURES
AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL. IT AT.
FUNDING UPDATES ARE PROVIDED IN
SEPTEMBER- IN ADDITION WE
CONTINUE. TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON ONE OF OUR-
CATEGORIES IN OUR LATEST FISCAL
UPDATE HAS YOU KNOW I. TEETH
DEEP ON THEIR ONLINE RELATED TO
THE VACCINE TASK FORCE IS KIND
OF. ANOTHER PIECE OF
INFORMATION THAT IS PENDING
THAT WE'RE NOT AT THE TO HAVE A
FISCAL ESTIMATE ON BUT THAT WE
WANT TO SIGNAL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND NOTING THAT
THAT THAT IS BEING CONTEMPLATED
AND CONSIDERED. SO AGAIN WE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO PROVIDE D.
THESE UPDATES AS WE HAVE THEM
ON FISCAL EXPENDITURES RELATED
TO THE PANDEMIC OKAY THANK YOU
OF THAT I MEAN YOUR ANSWER
ILLUSTRATES THE- THE PROBLEM
OKAY BECAUSE- WHAT I HEAR YOU
SAYING IS THAT. YOU HAVE BEEN
DOING YOUR BEST TO TELL US WHAT
YOU GUYS HAVE DECIDED AND WHAT
WE ARE SAYING IS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE INVOLVED IN THE
PROCESS OF DECIDING HOW TO
RESPOND TO THE EMERGENCY HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE THIS FUNDING. AND I
THOUGHT THE LEGISLATURE WAS
VERY CLEAR WHEN WE PASSED SB
EIGHTY NINE IN ARTICULATING THE
FACT THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
INVOLVED SO ARE OF IT DID YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT I'M SAYING THAT
YOU'RE SAYING WE MAKE THE
DECISIONS AND THEN WE TELL YOU
WHAT WE'VE DONE AND WHAT WE ARE
SAYING IS WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
INVOLVED IN THOSE DECISIONS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL- A
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
NOT ONLY KNOW ABOUT THE
SPENDING BUT IT. TO PERFORM
OVERSIGHT OF THAT SPENDING. NO
YES I AM I. HERE AND APPRECIATE
THE CONCERN AND WE WILL AND WE
WILL DEFINITELY MAKE NOTE AND-
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION WHICH
I THINK. IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO
THE DISCUSSIONS WE ARE HAVING
IN THE SPRING TO AND WANTED TO
ADD THE ADDITIONAL REPORTING
THAT WE'VE BEEN. PROVIDING WITH
THAT AT THE RESULT OF THOSE
TYPES OF DISCUSSIONS- AGAIN
MARCH OF MORE TRANSPARENCY AND
I'M MORE INFORMATION BEING
PROVIDED OKAY WELL THANK YOU I
MEAN I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO BE
INTROSPECTIVE ABOUT BECAUSE-
THIS WILL NOT BE THE LAST TIME
THAT WE HAVE. THE KIND OF
EMERGENCY THAT REQUIRES THIS
KIND OF SHARED OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY AND I THINK WE
NEED TO WORK THESE KINKS OUT SO
THEY WERE BETTER PREPARED NEXT
TIME. BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATED ABOUT. ABOUT OUR
LACK OF IN OF INVOLVEMENT IN
MAKING THESE DECISIONS AND- AND
REALLY FEELING LIKE- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS AN OBLIGATION TO BE
INVOLVED IN AND THEN THE KIND
OF A SIMILAR QUESTION FOR THE-
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE IF
WE COULD GET MISS PETERS BACK
ON- YOU OUTLINED SOME PRETTY-
SOME PRETTY STARK. PATHS FOR US
IS A LEGISLATORS THAT WE COULD
TAKE TO TRY TO VOTE ENGAGE MORE
IN THIS PROCESS- BUT I'M
WONDERING IF THERE IS NO MIDDLE
GROUND BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
ENDING THE DECLARATION OF THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY HAS
REPERCUSSIONS BEYOND JUST THE-
LEGISLATURES ENGAGEMENT AND- IN
SPENDING AUTHORITY SO I'M
WONDERING IF THERE ISN'T SOME
KIND OF MIDDLE GROUND OBVIOUSLY
CHANGING STATE LAW WOULD APPLY
TO FUTURE EMERGENCIES NOT TO
THIS ONE AND WOULD REQUIRE YOU
KNOW THE CONCURRENCE OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH- WOULD WHEN WE
DO THAT SO ARE WONDERING IF
THERE ARE WAYS THAT. THE L. A.
O. HAS A HAS MAYBE THOUGHT OF.
THAT WE COULD FIX THIS PROCESS
AND MORE INVOLVED THE
LEGISLATURE IN THOSE SPENDING
DECISIONS. THANK YOU MR
OBERNOLTE ADDRESS COMPUTERS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND- SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
WE WE'RE NOT RECOMMENDING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE- USE ITS
AUTHORITY TO AND THE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION. I'M JUST SORT OF
NOTING HOW THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY LAWS WORK- OBVIOUSLY
AS YOU POINT OUT THAT WOULD
HAVE SIGNIFICANT REPERCUSSIONS
pABLE TO RESPOND TO THE
EMERGENCY IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
AT AL. AND WE WERE ASKED TO
SPEAK TO POTENTIAL LONGER TERM
CHANGES- AND I THINK I'M
GETTING AT SOME OF THE
OVERSIGHT ISSUES AND QUESTIONS
THAT WE'VE RAISED. IT'S REALLY
THAT MIDDLE GROUND AREA- I'M
FOR YOU TO THINK ABOUT AT THIS
POINT AND THE MINISTRATION HAS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING MONTHLY
REPORTING. THIS INFORMATION AND
YOU JUST IT'S JUST LIKE A
REPORT BUT IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
VERY CRITICAL FOR YOU TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING. I'M IT REFLECTS NOT
ONLY THE TOTAL EXPENDITURE
LEVELS AND THE TOTAL BUDGETARY
IMPACTS AND- OF WHAT IS BEING-
HAS BEEN DONE AND IT ALSO IS
SHOWING THOSE PLANNED
ACTIVITIES IN THE FUTURE. I AM
GETTING THIS INFORMATION
UPDATED ONLY PERIODICALLY
REALLY IS LIMITING THE
LEGISLATURE'S OVERSIGHT OF THIS
RESPONSE TIME. AND ENSURING
THAT THOSE REPORTS SHOW BOTH
WHAT HAS BEEN EXPENDED ALREADY.
THE WELL AS WHAT IS PLANNED FOR
THE FUTURE I'M IS EXACTLY THE
KIND OF INFORMATION THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO BE ABLE.
TO ENGAGE MEANINGFULLY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS OR OTHER-
AVENUES THAT YOU HAVE THAT
WITHOUT HAVING THAT INFORMATION
OF WHAT HAS BEEN SPENT AND WHAT
THEY PLAN TO SPEND. YOU DON'T
EVEN HAVE THE BASE INFORMATION
THAT- IS REALLY NECESSARY FOR-
REALLY STRONG LEGISLATIVE
ENGAGEMENT HI I'M IN THIS
PROCESS IN A IN A REALLY
IMPACTFUL MEANINGFUL CONSISTENT
WAY. AND SO AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS WE RAISE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING THESE
ARE PER ON A MONTH BASIS. AND
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED YET YOU
KNOW THEY'RE WORKING TOWARDS IT
AND IT'S COMPLICATED BUT- I'M
IS GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR
YOU TO UNDERSTAND WHY THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO DO THIS- AND WATER
THOSE CHALLENGES AND WHAT STEPS
NEED TO BE TAKEN. TO OVERCOME
THOSE CHALLENGES ARE BECAUSE
JUST HAVING THAT THAT BASELINE
OF INFORMATION IS REALLY THE
FIRST I'M NECESSARY STOP. I'M
IN OVERSIGHT AND ENSURING THAT
IT SHOWS WHAT THEY SPENT AND
WHAT WHAT ARE SOME THE OUTCOMES
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AND WHAT
THEY'RE PLANNING TO DO AND WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE EXPECTED
OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT.
I JUST UNDERSTANDING THAT IS
GOING TO ALLOW FOR A LOT MORE
AND MEANINGFUL INVOLVEMENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE. I'M IN TERMS
OF SECTION THIRTY SIX THAT YOU
BROUGHT UP ON AND SORT OF
ADVANCE NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT'S NOT THE WAY
THE FUNDING IS CONSTRUCTED ON
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BUT
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
YOU COULD THINK ABOUT GOING
FORWARD. I'M EITHER CHANGING
THE STRUCTURE OF EMERGENCY
SPENDING OVERALL OR CHANGING IT
FOR JUST THIS PARTICULAR
EMERGENCY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS
EXACTLY AND I WOULD URGE
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE. TO
THINK SERIOUSLY ABOUT WHAT
CHANGES WE NEED TO MAKE TO
IMPROVE OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH BECAUSE WE
HAVE A- AN IMPORTANT FUNCTION
TO FILL. THIS EMERGENCY IS NOT
GOING TO BE OVER ANY TIME SOON
AS YOU POINTED OUT THE TREE
AUTHORITY IS GOING TO LAST
UNTIL. NEXT JULY FIRST SO THIS
IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE. FOR AT LEAST
ANOTHER SEVEN OR EIGHT MONTHS
AND- AS WE KNOW THE STATE'S
GONNA REQUIRE LONGER TO
RECOVER. THAN THAT- AND I
REALLY THINK THAT WE HAVE A
VALUABLE ROLE TO FULFIL HERE I
MEAN WE'RE- IF IT'S NOT A
ANOTHER GIVEN OVER WHO HAS THE
AUTHORITY AND THE POWER TO
SPEND MONEY- IT'S MORE OF A
SHARED RESPONSIBILITY. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HELP THE STATE
RECOVER AND WEAR THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND WE'RE THE ONES WITH
THE- CONNECTIONS INTO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WERE IN THE LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT'S OUR
FUNCTION AS REPRESENTATIVES AND
I THINK THAT- WE'RE WE BETTER
ENGAGED HERE WE DO WE COULD DO
A BETTER JOB IN HELPING.
SOMEONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE CANDIDATE ANSWER THE
QUESTION. CURTIS FAULCONER VICE.
ON QUESTIONS OF COULD. MISS
CALVERT- COMISKEY OF WHATEVER
THE QUESTION IS WHY. DLF HAS
NOT BEEN ABLE TO PRODUCE THE
MONTHLY REPORTS AND- IF SO WHEN
THOSE MONTHLY REPORTS FOR.
CURRENT. HI WE HAVE AN AS NOTED
WE OBSERVE A AN AUGUST UP. YOU
PROVIDED THIS NO UP WITH. WE
ALSO A SHIFT UPDATE RELATED TO
FUNDING SO WE DID NOT HAVE AN
OCTOBER UPDATE AND THEN YES WE
ARE OUR INTENT IS STILL TO
PROVIDE REGULAR UPDATES ON OUR
EXPENDITURE ESTIMATES WE HAVE-
SHIFTED THE WAY WE'VE BEEN
COLLECTING INFORMATION FROM
DEPARTMENT OR CONTINUE TO TRY
TO IMPROVE THAT APPROACH AND
GATHER THE INFORMATION. AND
RELAY FOR DIFFERENT PURPOSES
NOT ONLY IS IT THAT THE STATE
BUDGETARY EXPENDITURES BUT-
WORKING WITH OUR- OUR PUBLIC
THAT YES ON. AND FEMA
REIMBURSEMENTS AND MAXIMIZING
THE ALLOWABLE FEMA
REIMBURSEMENT AS WELL AS THE
REPORTING ASSOCIATED WITH THE
VARIOUS FEDERAL FUNDS AND CRF
MOST NOTABLY SO HOW CAN THIS
INFORMATION IS- SOMETHING WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND
REFINING. BUT AND JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT WE DID PROVIDE AN
AUGUST UPDATE AND WE PROVIDED
THE SEPTEMBER UPDATE ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDING SIDE- AND AGAIN
ON NOVEMBER FISCAL UPDATE. WITH
THE LATEST INFORMATION WE HAVE.
SO LET ME JUST ASK MISTER STERN
DURING CAN. CAN YOU SORT OF.
THIS DISCUSS HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RESPONSE HAS
IMPROVED. DURING THE TIME OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT ALSO-
REITERATE SORT OF WHERE THE
WHERE THE GAPS STILL REMAIN
MISS PETERS. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M SO I THINK AND THE
INITIATION IS PROVIDING REPORTS
AND THAT THEN MEAN WINDS IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THE
STATE'S- OVERALL DIRECT
FINDING. HAVE COME INTO MAY AND
AUGUST AND NOVEMBER THERE WAS-
AN INTERIM SEPTEMBER- UPDATE
PROVIDED THAT FOCUS JUST ON THE
FEDERAL FINES. AND N. B. WHEN
YOU PUT ALL THESE REPORTS
TOGETHER IT CAN SHOW A HELPFUL
PICTURE OF SORT OF THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE OVERALL
SPENDING AND THE STATE'S
RESPONSE. I'M ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT'S HAPPENING IS EACH TIME
THESE UPDATES CALM AND THE
OVERALL DOLLAR NOW AND
ACTIVITIES ARE CHANGING AND THE
IN SOME CASES BY HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OR BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND SO THINGS ARE OBVIOUSLY
INVOLVING RICK VERY RAPIDLY AND
AS- WE LEARN MORE ABOUT ON KOBE
NINETEEN AND THE INITIATION OF
FURTHER DEVELOPS ITS PLANS TO
RESPOND. AND THAT WHEN THINGS
CHANGED SO SIGNIFICANTLY FROM
YOU KNOW ONE UPDATE TO THE
NEXT. AND THAT SORT OF POINTS
TO THE LEGISLATURE NEEDING MORE
FREQUENT UPDATES AND MORE
TIMELY INFORMATION AND THE
OTHER THING IS IT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND. I'M IN
THESE UPDATES IT'S COMBINING
FUNDING FROM LAST FISCAL YEAR
WITH PLANNED FUNDING FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
THESE DOLLARS AND SPENT HOW
REMAINS. I'M WHAT DOES ASK HIM
IT'S HARD TO GET THROUGH THE
END OF THE FISCAL YEAR AND THEN
HOW DOES THAT TIE TO DIFFERENT
OUTCOMES AND A LOT OF FINDINGS
BEEN SPENT ON PROCUREMENT OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
WHICH OF TALK ABOUT IN THE NEXT
PANEL. BUT HOW MUCH HAS BEEN
SPENT AND WHAT WAS PURCHASED
FOR THAT AND- HOW MUCH REMAINS
AVAILABLE THOSE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS IT'S NOT REALLY CLEAR
FROM THOSE UPDATES- AND SO
GETTING FATTER INFORMATION AND
HAVE FREQUENT ENOUGH MANNERS
CAN BE VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. SYSTEMS PETERS IS
IT FAIR TO SAY JUST WHAT I'M
HEARING FROM YOU AS- YOU WANT A
CERTAIN CONSISTENCY WITH THE
REPORT SO THAT. YOU CAN COMPARE
MONTH TO MONTH AT THIS POINT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE DATA JOHN. A BIT
OF ALL OF THE PLACE SO IT'S
DIFFICULT TO. COMPARE WHAT
ACTUALLY WAS EXPENDED SAY
BETWEEN AUGUST AND NOVEMBER.
YEAH IT'S NOT POSSIBLE TO
DETERMINE WHAT AMOUNT HAS BEEN
EXPANDED VERSES WHAT PORTION OF
THE TOTAL REFLECTS PLANNED
EXPENDITURES TO GET THROUGH THE
REST OF THE FISCAL YEAR SO
THAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IF WE SPENT
WHAT DID THAT GET US WHAT WE
HAVE PLANNED. COMING FOR THE
REST OF THE YEAR AND HAVING
THAT INFORMATION AND YOU KNOW
TO BE ABLE IN THESE VERSIGHT
HEARING SAY THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE
PLANNING TO DO FOR THE REST OF
THE FISCAL YEAR WHAT ARE THE
OUTCOMES AND HAVE A MEANINGFUL
DISCUSSION OF THEM. INSTEAD OF
NOT HAVING THAT BASIC
INFORMATION. THANK YOU MISS
PERU SYSTEM IS COVERED THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE DONE.
THAT WE HAVE- REPORTING THAT.
IS CONSISTENT. FROM ONE MONTH
TO THE NEXT TO THAT WE CAN
DETERMINE WHAT WAS ACTUALLY
SPENT. IN THE INTERIM PERIODS
AS WELL AS- WHAT IS- PROJECTED
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM DAILY
HOURS. IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
DISSECT THAT DATA IN ITS
CURRENT FORMAT. YEAH I KNOW
WHAT WE PROVIDE IS A PRETTY
HIGH LEVEL WE REALLY TRIED TO
SHOW THAT TYPE OF COMPARISON WE
TRY TO SHOW YOU KNOW SINCE OUR
LAST UPDATE ON THESE TYPES OF
EXPENDITURES FROM AUGUST TO
NOVEMBER. I'M KIND OF A SIDE BY
SIDE OF WHAT THOSE ARE NOW I
WANT TO NOTE THAT IN THE
INTERIM THERE ARE THERE HAVE
BEEN OTHER UPDATES PROVIDED SO-
ONE OF OUR MAIN DIFFERENCES. IN
AUGUST TO NOVEMBER WAS THE
INCLUSION OF AND THAT THE
DIAGNOSTIC TESTING BUT THERE
WAS AN INTERIM UPDATE IN LATE
AUGUST SENT- AT ON ON THIS
MATTER SO IT'S NOT THAT AND
DISCUSSIONS REN'T HAPPENING
AND INFORMATION ISN'T BEING
PROVIDED UNTIL THESE FISCAL
UPDATES ARE PROVIDED THERE ARE-
NOTICES BEING SENT. AND
INFORMATION BEING PROVIDED IN
THE INTERNET AS WELL RIGHT
BIRTH PEOPLE WERE SAYING
DISCOVERED IS. DATA IS BEING
DUMPED. BUT AS AS YOU MENTIONED
MAYBE IT'S- TO HIGH LEVEL NOT
SPECIFIC ENOUGH. IT'S ALSO
DIFFICULT TO DISCERN. SO I'LL
JUST GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE I MEAN
WE COULD GIVE ANYBODY. YOU KNOW
MILLIONS OF DATA POINTS BUT
FRANKLY IT DOESN'T TELL US
ANYTHING UNLESS YOU ACTUALLY
SYNTHESIZE IT AND CAN COMPARE-
INFORMATION. SO IF YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE- HERE WE ARE WE HAVE A
PROBLEM AT THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA THE UNIVERSITY.
CALIFORNIA JUST GIVE EXAMPLE
EVERY YEAR. THEY WERE PASS A
BUDGET. BUT THEY NEVER. ENTERED
THE REGENTS WHAT THE ACTUALLY
SPEND MONEY ON TO EVERY YEAR
THEY GO THIS YEAR'S BUDGET WAS
THIS AND LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
WITH THIS BUT NO ONE EVER TOLD
THEM WHAT. WHAT WHAT WAS
ACTUALLY SPENT. SO I THINK WHAT
WE'RE- SAYING TO YOU IS- IN
YOUR MIND YOU'RE GIVING US
INFORMATION. WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IT'S HARD TO COMMUNICATE IS
THAT THE INFORMATION IN THE
FORMAT IS PRESENTED MAY MAKE
YOU FEEL LIKE YOUR MEETING YOUR
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS. BUT IT
REALLY DOESN'T FOR FILL THE
TRANSPARENCY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
IN THE OPEN THIS OBLIGATION
THAT WE HAVE AN OPEN SOCIETY.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ASK IF YOU CAN WORK
WITH THE L. A. O. TO. GET THE
REPORT FORMAT THAT- IS A LITTLE
MORE LOW LEVEL A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATIVE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
IS- MORE EASILY DIGESTIBLE.
BECAUSE JUST AS AS I'M ON THE
RECEIVING END OF THESE LETTERS
THERE'S JUST SORT OF LIKE. DOES
SHE JUST- IT'S JUST PAPER JUST
COMING THROUGH THE DESK IT
DOESN'T REALLY. MEANS THAT MUCH
FROM AN OVERALL PICTURE. SO I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND WHAT
WE WHAT WE UNDERSTAND IN THE
SPRING WE WERE STILL STRUGGLING
JUST TO CONTAIN THINGS NOW THAT
AT LEAST HAS THE STATE HAS HAD
SOME SUCCESSES WOULD HAVE
MANAGING AS BEST AS WE COULD
THE PANDEMIC. IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO TAKE THE TIME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE TAKEN A
LOOK BACK AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT
WAS SPENT AND THEN TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT. WHAT WE PLAN
ON SPENDING MOVING FORWARD.
YEAH I KNOW WHERE I AM. ALWAYS
ALWAYS HAPPY TO KEEP TALKING
THE WITH THE L. A. L. WE HAVE I
JUST I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
WE HAVE INVOLVED IN THE
REPORTING SO WE DO HAVE- MORE.
MORE LINES AND MORE SPECIFICITY
THAN WHEN WE STARTED SO WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO REFINE HOW WE
PRESENT IT TO MAKE IT. AS
USEFUL AS POSSIBLE AND FIND
THAT BALANCE OF LIKE YOU SAID
BE DIGESTIBLE- BUT ALSO HAVING
THE INFORMATION THE FOLKS ARE
LOOKING FOR SO. AND WE'LL
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION
DON'T CONTINUE- AS WE WORK ON
IT HURT TO REFINE THAT FORMAT
AND SEE WHAT. IS THAT AT A
HELPFUL WAY TO COMMUNICATE THAT
INFORMATION AND THEN IF IT IF
YOU FOR THAT AGAIN. I MEAN WHAT
WE HOPE IS THAT THESE CHANGES
BE COMMUNICATED BETWEEN FINANCE
AND L. A. ALL IN. THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE. IT OVERSIGHT
HEARING I THINK A LITTLE BIT OF
OUR FRUSTRATION IT FEELS LIKE-
THINGS DON'T GET. TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY UNTIL WE START
SCHEDULING OVERSIGHT HEARING
SO. OUR PREFERENCES- YOU KNOW
YOU YOU HAVE YOUR JOB. WE HAVE
OUR JOB WE'RE TRYING TO GIVE
FEEDBACK AND I THINK WE'RE ALL.
RUN THE SAME TEAM WE WILL WE'RE
ALL WORKING TO. MANAGE THIS
PANDEMIC WE'RE ALL WORKING TO
TRY TO SAVE LIVES- YOU KNOW ALL
ACROSS THE STATE WORLD WE ALL
HAVE EXACTLY. THE SAME GOAL
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
DIFFERENCE IN GOALS I THINK WE
ARE. JUST TRYING TO AGAIN DO DO
OUR JOB JUST LIKE YOU ARE. SO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW YOU COULD.
YOU COULD YOU COULD HELP US IF
WE CAN HELP YOU IN THE- THE
WHOLE POINT IS THAT WE NEED TO.
I THINK WORK BETTER TOGETHER ON
THIS- ON. HOW. WE ARE
COMMUNICATING ON THIS
PARTICULAR SHIP. SO DO WE HAVE
MISTER DEPUTY DIRECTOR. FOR NOW.
THAT THAT THE DOCTOR FINALLY.
HE ASKED- THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST
FINE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU CAN GO AHEAD OF THEM
WILL GO TO MISTER COOPER AFTER.
GO AHEAD OF THE GREAT. OKAY
GOOD MORNING TEARS A MEMBERS
I'M SEASON FINALE GAP CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST
IN THE STATE'S WORK IN
PREPARING FOR PUBLIC VACCINE
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON OUR VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION PLANNING. FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC DATA
AND SCIENCE HAVE GUIDED THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO COVER
NINETEEN WELL THERE IS NO FDA
APPROVED VACCINE YET
CALIFORNIA'S PLANNING PROCESS
FOR THE EVENTUAL DISTRIBUTION
AND MINISTRATION OF COVER
NINETEEN VACCINATION IS GUIDED
BY THE FOLLOWING OVERARCHING
PRINCIPLES. ENSURING PREVENT
NINETEEN VACCINE MEET SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS ENSURING THAT THE
VACCINE IS DISTRIBUTED AND
ADMINISTERED EQUITABLY. AND
ENSURING TRANSPARENCY BY
BRINGING AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS FROM THE OUTSET.
TO VERIFY THE SAFETY OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN VACCINE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM RECENTLY NAMED
A SCIENTIFIC REVIEW WORKGROUP
COMPRISED OF NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED IMMUNIZATION PUBLIC
HEALTH ACADEMIC AND SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS FROM CALIFORNIA.
SHORTLY FOLLOWING THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT WASHINGTON OREGON
AND NEVADA JOINED OUR EFFORT
WITH EACH STATE GOVERNOR I'M
NAMING ADDITIONAL EXPERTS TO
THIS WORKGROUP. WORKGROUP IS
CHARGED WITH STAYING ABREAST OF
VACCINE TRIALS EVIDENCE OF
SAFETY AND EFFICACY AND OTHER
INFORMATION TO INDEPENDENTLY
PROVIDE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
STATE AND OUR VACCINE PLANNING
EFFORTS AS WELL AS ENSURE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN VACCINE
SAFETY ADVOCACY AND
IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ALSO ANNOUNCED
TWO ADDITIONALKEY GROUPS TO
ENSURE THE VACCINE IS
DISTRIBUTED AND MINISTERED
EQUITABLY. I DRAFTING
GUIDELINES WORK GROUP COMPRISED
OF IMMUNIZATION PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTHCARE AND ACADEMIC EXPERTS
AND ETHICISTS CHARGED WITH
DEVELOPING CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
GUIDANCE FOR THE PRIORITIZATION
AND ALLOCATION OF VACCINE WHEN
SUPPLIES ARE LIMITED SO THAT
INITIAL FACE. AN UPCOMING
COMMUNITY ADVISORY VACCINE
COMMITTEE THIS COMMITTEE WHOSE
MEMBERS HAVE NOT YET BEEN NAMED
WILL PROVIDE INPUT AND FEEDBACK
TO THE PLANNING EFFORTS. AND
THIS IS A DECISION MAKING FROM
A BROAD ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK DILIGENTLY
TO PREPARE FOR THE EVENTUAL
DISTRIBUTION MINISTRATION OF
THE VACCINE IN CALIFORNIA.
PLANNING WILL INVOLVE
CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MULTIPLE
STATE AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND WILL
LEVERAGE THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A ROUTINE
VACCINATION. CALIFORNIA'S COBA
NINETEEN VACCINATION PLAN WILL
BE IMPLEMENTED IN SEVERAL
PHASES- PRE VACCINE LIMIT DOES
AVAILABLE- LARGER NUMBER OF
DOSES ARE AVAILABLE IN THE-SECOND PHASE AND THEN.
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF A OF DOSES
FOR THE ENTIRE POPULATION.
CALIFORNIA'S VACCINATION
COMMUNICATION PLAN IS FOCUSED
ON ENSURING EVERYONE LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA RECEIVE TIMELY
ACCURATE AND THE ACTUAL
ACTIONABLE INFORMATION ABOUT
THE VACCINATION. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA HAS THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT VACCINATION FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY.
WILL BE TRANSPARENT OUR
COMMUNICATION AND FOCUS ON- FOR
SAFETY AND EQUITIES AND WE WILL
FOCUS ON THE ROLE AS A FAX
EMAIL PLAN BRINGING AN END TO
THE PANDEMIC. OUR COMMUNICATION
EFFORTS WILL ALIGN WITH THE
COVERT VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
TIMELINE AND WE WILL BE M. AND
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN FOUR
PHASES PRE VACCINE LIMITED
DOSES AVAILABLE PHASE ONE LARGE
NUMBER OF DOSES AVAILABLE FACE
TO YOU AND SUFFICIENT SUPPLY OF
DOSES FOR THE ENTIRE OPULATION
WHICH WOULD BE. A PHASE THREE
COMMUNICATIONS PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION WILL ALSO ALIGN
WITH THE STATE'S HEALTH EQUITY
METRIC WHICH HELPS GUIDE
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTY COUNTIES IN
THEIR CONTINUING EFFORTS. TO
MOVE MORE EFFECTIVELY FIGHT
OVER NINETEEN THE EQUITY METRIC
IS DESIGNED TO REDUCE CASES ON
THE OST DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES AS DEFINED
BY THE CENSUS TRACTS IN THE
LOWEST QUARTILE OF THE HEALTHY
PLACES INDEX- WITH LARGER
COUNTIES AS DEFINED BY
POPULATION AND GEOGRAPHY. OF
THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
SMALLER COUNTIES- WHERE HAVE A
DIFFERENT MEASURE AND AN EQUITY
PLAN BECAUSE THEY CANNOT BE A
MEASURED IN CENSUS TRACTS.
CALIFORNIA'S TAX COMMUTER
PLANNING INCLUDES INPUT FROM
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS EXPERTS
AND CRISIS COMMUNICATION.
PUBLIC AFFAIRS IMMUNIZATION AND
LEVERAGES HEALTHEQUITY WORK
ALREADY UNDERWAY AT THE STATE
AND LOCAL LEVELS. THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE VACCINATION
PROGRAM REQUIRE TIMELY
ACCESSIBLE AND EFFECTIVE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDANCE
DEVELOP WIRING IMMUNIZATION
TEAM AND HEALTH EDUCATION
SPECIALISTS. ARE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS WILL WORK CLOSELY WITH
FEDERAL LOCAL PARTNERS TO
CREATE. THE APPROPRIATE
GUIDANCE MEDIA AND PUBLIC
DISSEMINATION OF THIS GUIDANCE
THROUGH ALL COMMUNICATION
CHANNELS. THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER OF UNKNOWNS ABOUT THE
TIMING QUANTITY AND EFFICACY OF
THE VACCINE. IN ADDITION THERE
ARE SEVERAL VACCINES AT VARIOUS
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT. AND
TESTING- AND SO KEEPING ON TOP
OF THAT AND UNDERSTANDING WHICH
OF THE VACCINES WILL- COME OUT
FIRST AND WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS
WILL BE. CALIFORNIA WILL
LEVERAGE ITS WELL ESTABLISHED
EXISTING IMMUNIZATION FRAMEWORK
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO COORDINATE
OUR EFFORTS BETWEEN STATE LOCAL
AND TRIBAL AUTHORITIES. THE
ROLE OF DIFFERENT PARTNERS SUCH
AS HOSPITAL SYSTEMS HEALTH
CLINICS. APPLY IN THE STAGE OF
THE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION PLANT.
WE'LL BE BUILDING ON LESSONS
LEARNED FOR SEASONAL INFLUENZA
EFFORTS AS WELL AS THOSE
LEARNED DURING H. ONE AND ONE.
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE CHANGING QUANTITIES TIME
LINES THAT AND AVAILABILITY
WHETHER OR NOT SUPPLIES ARE AND
TRULY- PROVIDED BY OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEN
COMMUNICATION NEEDS IN TERMS
OF- DIFFERENT PHASES AND
AVAILABILITY BOTH ON THE SUPPLY
AND DEMAND SIDE. SEE PAGES IN
THE EARLY PROCESS OF RECRUITING
AND ROLLING VACCINE PROVIDERS
IN CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH OUR
LOVE HALTH LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. ARE IMMUNIZATION
COALITIONS AND STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ASSOCIATIONS.
WORK IS UNDERWAY TO ENSURE THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS ROBUST AND
WILL MEET EXTENSIVE AND BRIDGET
DATA REQUIREMENTS FROM CDC FOR
EXAMPLES- PROVIDERS NEED TO
REPORT A MENACE- DOSES WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS INTO THE DATA
SYSTEM. SO THE STATE COMMAND
REPORT TO CDC AT THIS TIME WE
ARE LEVERAGING PURGING CURRENT
SYSTEMS AND UPGRADE HARDWARE
SERVERS AND REQUIRE. IN THE
POSSIBILITY THAT A VACCINE IS
AVAILABLE THIS YEAR YOU MAY
HAVE SEEN THAT ANNOUNCED IT
COULD BE AVAILABLE AS SOON AS-
DECEMBER NINTH. AT THIS TIME-
WE ARE WORKING ON AN END TO END
SOLUTION THAT WE READY EARLY
NEXT YEAR AS A TO ACCOMMODATE
THE EXPECTED VOLUME AND DATA
TRANSFERS NEEDED I SUPPLY-
BECOMES MORE AVAILABLE. I JUST
WILL DATA DRIVEN WAY AN
EMPHASIS ON AT AND ALL
PROTECTING VULNERABLE. WELCOME
HEALTH. WILL BOTH MINISTER. AND
ALLOCATE DOSES IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS TO OTHER
PROVIDERS. ALLOCATIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN
ACCORDANCE TO A PRIORITIZATION
FRAMEWORK. THAT IS UNDER
DEVELOPMENT AND WILL BE MADE
ADDITIONAL BASED ON GUIDANCE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SEE PAGE ONE CORPORATE NATIONAL
PRIORITIZATION RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM THE FEDERAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES AND THE NATIONAL
ACADEMY OF MEDICINE TO GUIDE
PRIORITIZATION FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE PROCESS FOR ABOUT JUST WANT
A FOLLOW THE FEB GOVERNMENT
WILL MAKE OUR- OF VACCINE TO
EACH STATE. CALIFORNIA WILL BAN
ALLOCATE VACCINE BASED ON THE
PRIORITIZATION FRAMEWORK TO
EACH COUNTY. SOME MULTI COUNTY
ENTITIES OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENTS. THE COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WILL THEN ALLOCATE
TO THEIR PROVIDERS WHO IN TURN
WILL PLACE ORDERS IN THE STATE
SYSTEM. THE STATE WILL PROVE
ORDERS AND SENT TO CDC FOR FILM
AT VACCINE WILL BE SHIPPED
DIRECT. FROM THE MANNER
MANUFACTURERS OR FROM A FEDERAL
DISTRIBUTOR TO THE PROVIDERS SO
IT'S FROM THE FEDS TO THE
PROVIDER THE STATE DOESN'T TAKE
POSSESSION OF THE VACCINE. A
PROVIDER WILL NEED STATE
APPROVAL TO REDISTRIBUTE. THE
VACCINE TO ANOTHER SITE.
STORAGE ON HAND FRIENDLY ONE OF
THESE. WHICH IS THE FIZER ONE
REQUIRES. ORDER LOW. COLD CHAIN
FREE QUIT AND- TRAINING FOR
PROVIDERS. WE ARE WORKING
DEVELOP STATEWIDE BACKUP
SOLUTIONS FOR THE STORAGE AND
TRANSPORT OF THIS VACCINE- LARA
PLANNING FOR THIS NEED WE ARE
ALSO LAST QUARTER. SPINELLI BUT
WITH CD WHO WITH A WORKING ON A
SLEW FOR THAT HALF OF IF I
COULD ASK YOU TO PLEASE WRAP UP.
YES YEAH MY MOMMA VERY ON PEACE
A SAFER EFFECTIVE NINETY
VACCINE IS ONE OF THEM
IMPORTANT INTERVENTION TO AND
THE CLOVEN P. CALIFORNIA WILL
BE CAREFUL ABOVE ALL ADEQUATE
IN OUR AND BACKS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU THANK YOU GOING TO
THE STRIP CLUB. HISTORY'S
LARGEST INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
EVERYONE THOSE FOLKS THAT
INDUSTRY IS AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER. AND I THINK IF YOU IF
YOU LOOK AT IT AND THE COUPLE
SPENT PER PERSON AND REALLY
DRILL DOWN. INTO THE INTO THE
COUNTY'S SPECIAL CENTRAL VALLEY
YOU CAN SEE A BIG DISCREPANCY
SLIDE I'M TOO INTERESTED ABOUT
GETTING THAT INFORMATION WHERE
THE MONEY CAME FROM- BUT NOW
TURNING BACK TO MISS FANELLI.
TELL ME HAS THERE BEEN ANY
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. AS IT RELATES TO
THE VACCINE PLANNING. I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANY. I'M I AM NOT SURE
OF THAT OTHER THAN I'M WORKING
ON TO GET THIS INFORMATION OUT
I THINK WE HAVE SENT TO AN
EXECUTIVE SUMMARY OF OUR
VACCINE PLAN WE POSTED IT ON
OUR WEBSITE- OTHER THAN THAT
I'LL HAVE TO CHECK WITH THE
TEAM TO SEE WHAT OTHER
ACTIVITIES HAVE HAPPENED.
WITHIN HIS LEGISLATORS WE
SHOULD HAVE TO GO TO YOUR
WEBSITE TO GET THE INFORMATION
THEY SHOULD BE REALLY AVAILABLE
TO US- ALSO SURE- ONLY TALKED
ABOUT A STAKEHOLDERS- HOW
THEY'RE GONNA BE CHILLS OUT-
WHAT COMMUNITIES OR GROUPS ARE
YOU CONSIDERING CHOOSING. THE
STAKEHOLDERS. I THANK ALL THE
AND YOU READ READ SOME OFF
EARLY THAT IS UNDER. WE
CERTAINLY. WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
A BROADER ARRAY OF STAKEHOLDERS
REPRESENTED AND FROM A VARIETY
OF AREAS AND INCLUDE. YELP IS
CERTAINLY WORKERS AS WELL AS
AND MANY OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU. ALL
REPRESENT SO WE WILL- I THINK
WE CAN PROVIDE. A LIST OF THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND CERTAINLY
WOULD BE OPEN TO- SUGGESTIONS
AND REVIEW THOSE AS WE TRY TO
GET. AS REPRESENTATIVE OF AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AS WE CAN
SURE I THINK WOULD BE GREAT IF
YOU HAS REACHED OUT TO LIVE
THAT IS STILL UNDER FORMATION.
IF YOU TO REACH OUT TO THE TO
THE MEMBERS THE ASSEMBLY
BECAUSE WE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIANS AND WE HAVE REALLY
STRONG COMMUNITY TIES WITH OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE AND ALL
OF THOSE COMMUNITY GROUPS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES I'M SURE. MY
COLLEAGUES AND MYSELF WOULD BE
WILLING TO HELP YOU AND DO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN- MY QUESTION IS
WHEN WILL THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY. TO REVIEW THE
ACTUAL VACCINATION PLAN IN
DETAIL. PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND WILL THERE
BE ANY OF. LET'S WITH THE TO
WORKING GROUP'S AFFECTING
WORKING GROUP'S. WORKING THAT.
SO WE ARE HAPPY TO SHARE THE
IT'S AN INTERIM PLAN SO IT WILL
CONTINUE TO CHANGE AND WE'RE
OPEN TO YOUR FEEDBACK WERE
HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH A
COPY OF THE PLAN AS IT NOW
EXISTS UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
LEARN MORE ABOUT. THE VACCINE
AVAILABILITY AND EFFICACY EVERY
DAY AND SO WE ARE CONTINUING TO
MAKE CHANGES TO THAT PLAN I
THINK THE RUB IS THAT YOU KNOW
WE- WE FEEL SHE REACHED OUT TO
US TO BE A PARTNER IN THIS. AND
NOT YOU KNOW OR VICE VERSA WE
WANT TO BE ENGAGE WANT TO BE
INVOLVED IT'S IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE'RE IN A LOT. OF WE FEEL
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THIS
AFFECTS OUR CONSTITUENTS SO. I
WOULD HOPE THAT MAYBE FOR GOING
FORWARD YOU CAN REACH OUT TO
THE LEGISLATURE ONE ADOLESCENT
SOME OF THIS BECAUSE WE WANT TO
BE. DEFINITELY GAUGING OF
OFFICE. AND WE DO HAVE A
COMMUNICATION PLAN. WE DO HAVE
A COMMUNICATION PLAN THAT
INCLUDES AN EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS. AND ALSO A
ON LEGISLATIVE OUTREACH GROUP
SO. WE WILL BE DOING MORE OF
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD AGAIN.
OUR PLAN WAS JUST SUBMITTED IN
TERMS OF A VERY QUICK TIMELINE.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT IT WAS ON
THE FIRST DRAFT SURE- SO WHAT
WERE YOUR THOUGHTS AS FAR AS
WHEN THE PUBLIC WILL BE
ADVISED. WHAT ABOUT THE PART OR
PIRES IS ATION. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION OF VACCINES. AND
HOW ARE YOU HOW DO YOU PLAN ON
COMMUNICATING THAT. OUR MEETING.
THAT WE DO HAVE A WHOLE COME.
PLAN THE- I THINK WE'RE IN THE
EARLY. AS WE LEARN MORE. I'M WE
WILL AND CERTAINLY WANT TO BE
AS TRANSPARENT WE KNOW THAT. WE
HAVE TO BUILD TRUST WE HAVE TO
IF THIS IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND WE NEED IT TO
BE. THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
EXTENSIVE COMMUNICATIONS WITH
THE PUBLIC ON THE LEGISLATURE
AND WITH OUR STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY. SO THAT IS ALL UNDER
WAY WE'RE HAPPY TO SHARE A
COMMUNICATION PLAN AS WE-
FINISH THAT UP AND GET YOUR
INPUT. THANK YOU AND IT FINALLY
WHAT'S THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN TO
ADDRESS THOSE. REFUSE TO
VACCINATE VACCINATED. INCLUDING
BATH DEFINITELY. I'D THINK
THERE ANY PLAN TO MAKE
VACCINATION MANDATORY AND SO WE
ARE HOPING THAT THROUGH
EDUCATION AND THROUGH. OUR
SAFETY ANALYSIS THAT WE
CONVINCE CAN COMMENCE AS MANY
PEOPLE- AND- CAN SAY WITH SOME
CERTAINTY THAT IT IS SAFE AND
THAT WE WOULD BE. ENCOURAGING
THROUGH EDUCATION NOT AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS GET VACCINATED AS
POSSIBLE. SURE AND I WAS
IMPLYING THAT WE FORCED
VACCINATIONS BUT WE DO HAVE
THAT SIGNAL A PUBLIC THAT. HAS
THEIR DOUBTS ALUMINUM. DESERVED
AND LET'S SEE IF THE PLANNING
ON HOW YOU PLAN ON BRINGING
THEM EXCESSIVELY. TO GET A CALL
THERE IMMUNITY. WE WALKED LIKE
TO GET ME PEOPLE VACCINATED. SO
I'M RIGHT I THINK WE CAN PLAY A
PART IN HELPING YOU. GET THAT
MESSAGE OUT THERE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER DOCTOR
READY CERTAIN ON WANT US. GO GO
GO AHEAD WITH ARE GOING PLEASE
GO AHEAD TOUGH THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND WE SORT
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE TO-
MAKE SURE THAT THE VACCINE IS
SAFE WE NEED TO GET THAT
MESSAGE OUT WILL BE COUNTING ON
ALL OF YOU TO HELP US WITH THAT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DOCTOR AND I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO
MANY OF YOU TO DETERMINE WHY I
WAS LOOKING INTO- PRESIDENTS
WHO ARE ONE TERM BUT IF WE LOOK
BACK TO SEVENTY FIVE YEARS AGO
WHEN WE WENT THROUGH THE GREAT
DEPRESSION IT WAS PRECEDED BY
HERBERT HOOVER. AND I WISH TO
SPEAK ABOUT FDR BECAUSE HE HAD
A QUOTE THAT I THINK IS
PARTICULARLY APPLICABLE TODAY.
THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS HELD THE
HOPE. THE BELIEF THE CONVICTION
THAT THERE IS A BETTER LIFE A
BETTER WORLD TO BE ON THE
HORIZON. AS WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF THIS PANDEMIC OF THE CENTURY
I HOPE OUR STATE IS LOOKING
TOWARDS THE HORIZON IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE AN
OVERARCHING PLAN. AND SO MY
QUESTION FOR MR CURRY IS. AS
WELL AS MISS FANELLI IS WHAT IS
THAT OVER ARCHING PLAN ARE WE
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE LOOKING
TOWARDS OUR ECONOMY AND
FOCUSING ON RECOVERY. WALLET
GEOLOGY THAT THE BEST WAY FOR
US TO GET OUR ECONOMY UP AND
RUNNING IS FOR US TO CONTROL
THE VIRUS. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE INTEGRATING THE
BLUEPRINT FOR A SAFER KANEMI
INTO THIS OVER ARCHING PLAN AND
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE WILLING%
TO SHARE IT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. THE QUESTION IS
FOR MR CURRIER MISS FINALE I
BELIEVE. HI THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SORRY LITTLE BIT OF A
DELAY ON THE TECHNICAL-
ABSOLUTELY I THINK AS I ALLUDED
TO WHEN I DISCUSS THEIR
EMERGENCY ORGANIZATION THAT YOU
KNOW NOT ONLY COMES TOGETHER
WHEN WE HAVE DISASTERS AND
EMERGENCIES BUT- ALSO HAS COME
TOGETHER FOR THIS EMERGENCY IS
THAT ABSOLUTELY THE FOCUS AND
REALLY AKA A CORE COMPONENT OF
THE ORGANIZATION IS TO LOOK
AHEAD- WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
CALLED ADVANCE PLANNING LOOKING
DOWN THE HORIZON- I'M NOT
TRYING TO. MINIMIZE OR
MARGINALIZE THE INCREDIBLE
IMPACT IN EVERY CORNER OF OUR
SOCIETY THAT IS AFFECTED BY
THIS DISEASE IN THE DECISION
MAKING- THAT WE DO NOW AND HOW
THAT AFFECTS LATER- BUT WE-
ABSOLUTELY ARE ARE LOOKING
AHEAD AND WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS TO- TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
TALK ABOUT TALK THROUGH THAT
TOGETHER I KNOW WE'VE HAD.
SEVERAL FORUMS AN UPDATE
SPECIALIZED- DISCUSSIONS AND IF
ENOUGH ADVANCE PLANNING IS ONE
OF THEM THEN WE'RE OPEN TO- TO
HAVING A DIALOGUE ABOUT THAT
BUT- YOU KNOW ART OUR JOB BACK
HELLO YES IS ALSO TO MANAGE THE
RECOVERY FROM DISASTERS NOT
JUST THE RESPONSE AND- MAYBE
THAT MANIFESTS TRADITIONALLY
AND THINGS LIKE WILDFIRES IN
THE REBUILDING AND DEBRIS
CLEANUP- BUT CERTAINLY IT COMES
INTO PLAY HERE- IT IS JUST- NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS TYPICAL AND
BY ANY STRETCH AND LOOKING AT.
THAT YOU KNOW ECONOMIC RECOVERY
AND KEEPING THEM IN MIND ALL OF
THE ELEMENTS THAT AFFECT PEOPLE
IN THIS TYPE OF EVENTS BEYOND
THE HEALTH AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT OUR ROLE IS TO DRAW IN THE
US THE ALL OF THE ELEMENTS OF
STATE GOVERNMENT- BRING IN THE
FEDERAL RESOURCES AND
IMPORTANTLY MOST IMPORTANTLY
WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITIES WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE
WHICH ARE VERY UNIQUE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND DO THAT WORK IN
REAL TIME AND ALSO LOOKING
AHEAD SO- MAYBE THAT ISN'T
SPECIFICALLY ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT YOU KNOW
DOCUMENT A PIECE OF PAPER BUT-
THE FACT THAT OF ADVANCE
PLANNING A LOOKING AHEAD IT AT
WHAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO. DO
IN ORDER TO ALTERNATELY OVER
COMMON AND MOVE FORWARD FROM
THIS. THIS PARTICULAR BAND IS
AS IMPORTANT AS WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN REAL TIME IMMEDIATELY
TO RESPOND- TO THINGS ARE
CHANGING EVERY DAY. IN TERMS OF
CASES AND HOW WE'RE SUPPORTING
OUR COMMUNITIES TO MANAGE THOSE
SO. I'M JUST HAPPY TO. TO I
TALK MORE ABOUT THAT AND HOW WE
CAN AND DOES COMMUNICATE AND
COORDINATE. IN THAT AREA IN THE
FUTURE AND I DON'T KNOW SUSAN
HAS ANYTHING TO ADD BUT SHE'S
HERE IN THE- ROOM. WITH ME AS
WELL. I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE
BLUEPRINTS IF. THAT THE
BLUEPRINT THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
IS DESIGNED TO HELP US TO.
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS
AND TO LOOK AT. BOTH THE HEALTH
AND- PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH
CARE IMPACTS ON SO AS WE LOOK
THROUGH. THAT PLAN OF HOW WE-
USE SURVEILLANCE AND
EPIDEMIOLOGY TO UNDERSTAND THAT
DISEASE TRANSMISSION. AND
PEOPLE COUNTIES MOVE FROM TIER
FORWARD OR BACK BASED ON THAT
TRANSMISSION CASE RATE AND-
TEST POSITIVITY OF TWELVE WELL
OTHER HEALTH EQUITY MEASURE.
THAT THAT TYPE TRAITS THE
ABILITY TO REALLY CONTROL ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
DISEASE AND AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
SEEING. A SLIGHT INCREASE IN AN
INCREASE IN CASES AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS RIGHT NOW. AND
SO REALLY PLANNING FOR THAT AND
REALLY PUTTING IN PERSPECTIVE-
ALL OF THOSE PIECES THAT NEED
TO BE IN PLACE FROM. THE APTIAN
SURVEILLANCE TO TESTING TO
CONTACT TRACING. AND THEN ON TO
VACCINE PLANNING. WHEN I
STARTED I HAD BROUGHT UP FDR
BECAUSE I REALLY BELIEVE HE
HELPED US THROUGH THE GREAT
DEPRESSION TO LOOK TOWARDS THE
SOCIAL SAFETY NET AS- SOMETHING
THAT HELPED OUR COUNTRY DURING
TIMES OF THE DAY. AND SO MY
QUESTION IF I CAN IS HOW ARE WE
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
ALL WE CAN FOR THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. THAT
WOULD GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE
SPECIFICALLY. WE HEARD TODAY
HOW UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE NUMBER
ONE COST DRIVER WITHIN. WHAT WE
ARE SPENDING OUR RESOURCES ON.
BUT THOSE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE WE-
TALKED OR THOUGHT ABOUT THEIR
HOUSING NEEDS THEIR FOOD
INSECURITY AND- OTHER SERVICES
THAT THEY MAY HAVE NEEDS IN
THIS TIME OF CRISIS. SO AT
THINK WE ARE TRYING TO LOOK. WE
ARE TRYING TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ALL OF THOSE THINGS WE'VE HAD
WE'VE ON IS TO HAVE NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS ACROSS SOCIAL SERVICES
IF YOU LOOK AT HOUSING TO LOOK
AT DELIVERY OF FOOD FOR
SPECIFIC POPULATIONS AND WE DO
AGREE THAT YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
HARDEST HIT POPULATIONS ARE HIT
ON MULTIPLE FRONTS FROM PAY-
YEAH PAY DISPARITY TO YOU KNOW
HOUSING TO FOOD PROGRAMS AND IF
WE KNOW THAT. IF WE WANT FOLKS
TO GET THROUGH THIS AND ALSO TO
ISOLATE QUARANTINE AS NEEDED IF
THEY ARE EXPOSED OR IN FACT AT
THAT ALL OF THOSE THINGS NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER ONE OF THE
CATALYSTS- INDEED FOR THIS WAS
A HEALTH EQUITY MEASURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE- PROGRESS AND
DO BETTER IN THE STATE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS DO BETTER AND NOT
HEALTHEQUITY MEASURE WAS
INSTITUTED FOR THAT VERY REASON
TO LOOK AT THAT SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH. EARLIER
ON OUR CHAIR HAD ASKED ABOUT
WHAT GAPS EXIST AND I BELIEVE
IT ASKED FINANCE ABOUT IT AND I
WANTED TO GIVE BOTH THE PH AND-
YEAH SO CHANCE TO. ANSWER WHAT.
GAPS THEY'VE NOTICED IN OUR-
DELIVERY OF CARE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND- WHAT'S BEING DONE
TO MEET THOSE GAPS. BETWEEN I
THINK WE'VE WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO ADDRESS EVERY GAP AS WE- WE
HAVE NOTICED THEM I THINK THAT.
CLEARLY ONE OF THE GAPS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO GUARD AGAINST AS
TRYING TO CONTROL DISEASE
TRANSMISSION SO THAT OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM STAYS- ABLE TO DEAL
WITH THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
FACT THAT AND SO I THINK THAT.
NATIONALLY YEAH THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH STAFF IN- AND HEALTH
CARE AND SO HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT WE TITRATE SORT OF OPENING
UP SECTORS LOOKING AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS IN OUR
HEALTH CARE INSTITUTIONS OR IN
OUR HOSPITALS PARTICULARLY- YEP
KEEP OUR HEALTH SYSTEM STRONG
ENOUGH TO DEAL WITH THE
EVERYBODY COMING IN. SO I GAP
IF THIS GETS BIGGER IT WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE HOW CLINICAL
STAFFING AND SO WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT IT WILL BE A NATIONAL
PROBLEM. SO I LOVE THE WAY THAT
YOU ANSWER THAT AND IF I COULD
I WOULD SAY WE'VE NEED A
FEDERAL PARTNER TO HELP TO LEAD
DURING THIS CRISIS AND REALLY
WOULD. LOOK TO THEM TO HELP US
TO MEET ANY GAPS THAT MAY
EXIST. NOW SINCE YOU MENTIONED
PROVIDERS. YOU KNOW I'M A
RECOVERING POSITION I ACTUALLY.
PROVIDED CARE MYSELF BUT
HAVEN'T BEEN IN THE R. FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS. AND SO NOW I
ACTUALLY LIKE TO THINK OF MY
SISTER WHO STILL IS PRACTICING
AND HI SIR SHE'S A NURSE
EDUCATOR THERE. AND I THINK A
LOT ABOUT THE PANDEMIC FIFTEEN.
THAT THIS TAKES WEEKS IT TAKES
MONTHS IT IS NOT EASY ON THOSE
WHO ARE. WORKING IN THE MIDST
OF THIS EVERY DAY AND SO MY
QUESTION IS WHAT ARE WE DOING
FOR RESILIENCY. HOW ARE WE
MAKING SURE THAT WERE
SUPPORTING THE PROVIDERS AS
WELL AS WORKING ON PATHWAYS FOR
FUTURE PROVIDERS. WE'RE WE'RE
CERTAINLY TRYING TO SUPPORT
THEM WITH STAFFING WITH. FOOD
SO WE HELP THEM WITH STAFFING
WITH TECHNICAL EXPERTISE WITH
I'M ONGOING DIALOGUE SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND ANY GAPS OR PROBLEMS
THAT THEY'RE HAVING. ARE ON
HEALTH. HEALTHCARE ACQUIRED
INFECTIONS PROGRAM PROVIDES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO OUR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES EVERY DAY
WE HAVE ONGOING DIALOGUE WITH
WEEKLY WEBINARS FOR BOTH SNAPS
AS WELL AS- OUR HOSPITALS. AND
RELATED MEETING WITH THE
ASSOCIATION THE PROVIDER
ASSOCIATIONS ON A ON GOING
BASIS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND. ANY GAPS WE ARE
ISSUING GUIDANCE ON WEEKLY TO
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE WE HAVE ALSO YOU KNOW A
LOT OF STAFFING WAIVERS FOR
THOSE AREAS WHERE WE HAVE RUN
INTO STAFFING- ISSUES- SO
REALLY I THINK OPENING THAT
DIALOGUE MAKING SURE WE'RE
AWARE OF ANY OF TOSE GAPS AND
THEN. WORKING WITH OUR PROVIDER
ASSOCIATIONS AND OUR FACILITIES
AND SYSTEMS. TO ADDRESS ANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT COME UP. YOU
KNOW I WIL AND- OUR PRESIDENT
ELECT ACTUALLY REMINDED ME OF A
SONG. HE SAID WEEPING MAY
ENDURE FOR THE NIGHT BUT JOY
COMETH IN THE MORNING. MANY OF
US HAVE FELT LIKE THIS IS A NEW
DAY FOR US HERE IN AMERICA AND
THERE IS A LOT OF ENJOY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US HERE IN THE
STATE BUT I WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO AGAIN COMPLEMENT OUR
GOVERNOR WHO I REALLY FELT TOOK
THE BULL BY THE HORNS. DURING
THE MIDDLE OF THIS CRISIS AND
THAT THE ACTION HELPED TO SAVE
LIVES IN CERTAIN PARTS OF OUR
CITY. AND SO REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS WE ARE GOING
FORWARD THERE WERE ACTUALLY
MAKING A PLAN THAT'S GOING TO
WORK WITH THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO ANSWER ASK
QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR. THANK
ARAMBULA I THINK. MISSED MISTER
GRAY HAD. IF YOU QUESTIONS. FOR
THE RECORD QUICKLY THOUGH NEED
TO MOVE TO OUR FINAL PANEL BUT
BOTH FOR OUR CUSTOMERS SERVICES
AS WELL AS- DEPARTMENT
CONFIRMED CAL REGISTED YEAH WE
TALKED A NUMBER THE MEMBERS
HERE HAVE TALKED. ABOUT THE-
REALITY IN AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE SOCIAL
WORKERS ARE THE NORM. AND THE
LACK OF RESOURCES BOTH
FINANCIALLY THAT HAVE MADE IT
TO OUR COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS-
PP SUPPLIES TESTING ETCETERA.
N. WITH THE PEAKS AND VALLEYS
OF. INFECTION OUR IT SEEMS THAT
I KNOW OF MY DISTRICT WE CAN
ONE WEEKLY TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING DOWN TESTING CENTERS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BEING
UTILIZED. AND THE NEXT WEEK.
TALKING ABOUT MOVING INTO YOU
KNOW PURPLE TEAR- PROVIDERS-
INFECTION RATES AND- THAT'S
EXTRAORDINARILY FRUSTRATING CHU
HAS ANYONE CONSIDERED THE
POSSIBILITY. OF PUTTING
TOGETHER A RAPID RESPONSE TEAM
FROM DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND DOOR YES OR SOME
COMBINATION OF. WHEN AN
EMPLOYER IN AN AREA HAS AN
OUTBREAK. RATHER THAN ALL THE
BUREAUCRATS AND POLITICIANS
PONTIFICATING ABOUT HOW
SOMEBODY SHOULD DO SOMETHING WE
pTO THE EPIDEMIC RIGHT TO THE
HOT SPOT AND DEAL WITH THAT
WHEN I SAID RESOURCES I MEAN
TESTING. EP SUPPLIES WHATEVER
THAT EMPLOYER NEEDS I KNOW I'VE
HEARD IN OTHER STATES THIS KIND
OF AN APPROACH. IN MY
EXPERIENCE CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL
MY COLLEAGUES FROM MY
EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN IN OUR
STATE. WE'RE SIMPLY- KIND OF
TELLING THE PRIVATE SECTOR WITH
THE SHOULD BE DOING BUT WHEN
THEY SAY BACK TO US HEY. I
CAN'T ACQUIRE THE RESOURCES OR
YOU KNOW I CAN'T GET THE
TESTING CAPACITY WE DON'T SEEM
TO HAVE AN ANSWER FOR THAT- HAS
THAT. TYPE OF A SEAL TEAM SIX
CORONAVIRUS RAPID RESPONSE
OCCURRED TO ANYONE. VERY MUCH
IN LINE WITH SOME OF OUR NEW
EFFORTS AS WE BRING ON THE
PERKINELMER LAB AND WE BRING ON
ON THIS MOBILE TESTING WE HAVE
BEEN DOING SORT OF THE STRIKE
FORCE TEAMS GOING INTO COUNTIES
AND WORKING WITH THEM WE HAVE
BROUGHT TOGETHER CDFA THAT
COUNTY HOW OSHA ARE AND- ALL
THE DISK DIFFERENT ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES AS WELL AS THE
EDUCATION- ENTITIES TO. TRY TO
COME TOGETHER AND ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF EMPLOYERS AND DRESS
THE NEEDS OF AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES AND OTHER ESSENTIAL
ON BUSINESSES SO I THINK IT IS
THE EXACTLY ON OUR MINDS OF HOW
TO DO MORE OF THAT AND AS WE
NOW HAVE CONTRACTS TO BRING ON
MORE MOBILE TESTING MORE
RESOURCES FOR TESTING AND- WE
WILL BE DOING MORE OF THAT AND
WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS I THINK
THAT. YEAH WE HAVE CONTINUED
THAT EFFORT NOT ONLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE BOTTOM WITH
IMPERIAL COUNTY STARTING AT AND
NOW LOOKING AT A FEW SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES WHERE THERE
ARE ENFORCEMENT EMPLOYER AND
WORKER ISSUES AS WELL SO I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT AND WE
AGREE THAT THOSE STRIKE TEAMS
AND NOT ALL OF GOVERNMENT
REALLY DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE
ON THE HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE-
IN MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
DATE. WELL IT JUST FOR BREAK
I'VE- EXPERIENCED CONVERSE.
WITH PUBLIC HEALTH OR WITH WITH
OH YES- WHERE WE'RE ASKING
THESE QUESTIONS. AND THERE
HASN'T BEEN A RESPONSE I'M GLAD
TO HEAR THAT THAT'S OUT THERE.
I'D LIKE TO BE. MADE IT'S
REALLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
DETAILS OF THOSE PLANS AND I'D
LIKE TO HAVE THE PHONE NUMBER
SO THAT I CAN CALL IT WHAT
WE'RE FACING THESE ISSUES IN MY
DISTRICT GET IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
BECAUSE- MY EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING. SO
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER BUT I DO
WANNA. HAVE SOME OFFLINE FOLLOW
UP ON THAT TOPIC. SURE WE'RE
HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP. A QUICK
QUESTION FOR HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP.
Q. SO MUCH A QUICK QUESTION FOR
W. DIRECTOR FROM CURRY- I KNOW
AS AS WE SORT OF STARTED OFF
THE HEARING. ALL WE ASK IS USED
TO WORKING IN A PARTICULAR
FASHION AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
GIVEN THE URGENCY IN THE NATURE
OF EMERGENCIES. NOW THERE WILL
BE A STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT IS
INDEFINITE- ARE YOU HAVE HAVE
YOU CHANGED OR WHAT PROTOCOLS
HAVE YOU CHANGED. YOU KNOW AS
YOUR OPERATING THIS PANDEMIC
THAT HAS SUCH AGAIN AN
EXPANSIVE VIEW YOU TOUCH EVERY
PART OF THE STATE YOU TOUCH
EVERY PERSON IN THE STATE- AND
SO GIVEN THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SAY A WILDFIRE
OR EVEN A DROUGHT WORDS VERY
SPECIFIC- SO WHAT PROTOCOLS
HAVE YOU CHANGE AND HOW YOU'RE
OPERATING IN REFERENCE TO THIS
PANDEMIC I THINK IN PARTICULAR-
OUR FRUSTRATIONS OF LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN- TRADITIONALLY THE
LEGISLATORS WHOSE AREAS ARE
IMPACTED- BY A PARTICULAR
EMERGENCY WORK VERY VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE WE US THAT'S
BEEN THE FEEDBACK WHETHER IT'S-
YOU KNOW FOR MR GALLAGHER. OR
FROM YOUR DOCTOR WORD ON THE
FIELD JUST THEIR THEIR OR THEIR
PARTNER IN THAT RESPONSE
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY LEGISLATORS
THAT ARE TOUCH IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR EVERYBODY TO FEEL
THAT SAME LEVEL OF OWNERSHIP
AND OBVIOUSLY THE SCALE OF
WHICH IS TO ME THAT YOU'VE
NEVER PROBABLY IN YOUR LIFETIME
NEVER HAD TO DEAL WITH AND
HOPEFULLY WE NEVER WILL HAVE TO
YOU KNOW HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THIS. SORT OF SCOPE AGAIN CAN
YOU. JUST WALK US THROUGH IT
YOU KNOW. PLEASE OF WHAT WHAT
CHANGE HAVE BEEN AWARE TO YOU
PLAN MAKING TO. KIND OF ADAPT
TO THE- SIZE OF A EMERGENCY.
AND THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND ABSOLUTELY OUR
SYSTEM WAS DESIGNED IT'S BEEN
AROUND IN CALIFORNIA FOR A LONG
TIME KNOWING THAT WE HAVE. A
MULTI HAZARD FOCUS AND- YOU
KNOW AND IT WAS DESIGNED WITH
IN MIND YOU KNOW THE ABILITY TO
BE FLEXIBLE FOR WHATEVER WE
FACE BUT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT IT'S REALLY UNPRECEDENTED
ICERTAINLY IN MY EXPERIENCE TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT NOT ONLY
REACHES WE'VE HAD DISASTERS
THAT HAVE TOUCHED EVERY
CALIFORNIA ALL AT ONCE WE'VE
HAD FLOODS WE'VE HAD THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS BUT THIS ONE- WITH
THAT SO MANY FACETS OF IT. AND
THAT ARE AFFECTING EVERY PART
OF SOCIETY REALLY IS UNUSUAL
AND- A CHALLENGE TO MAKE SURE
THEY WERE COHESIVE AND
COORDINATED AND- AS RESPONSIVE
OR AM IN COMMUNICATING OUR
RESPONSIVENESS. AS AS THE SAME
WAY THAT WE ARE ABLE TO DO
SUCCESSFULLY AS YOU MENTION AND
WILD WILDFIRES AND EARTHQUAKES
THINGS ARE LITTLE MORE
GEOGRAPHICALLY CENTRIC- SO I
CAN SAY THAT AND WE LEARNED A
LOT- YOU KNOW A LOT OF THIS WAS
UNPRECEDENTED WE DIDN'T KNOW WE
DID THINGS DIDN'T GO PERFECTLY.
AND HOPEFULLY WE'VE IMPROVED
AND ADJUSTED I'VE SEEN THAT
HAPPEN JUST WITH A DIFFERENT
FORMS THAT WE'VE- HAD WE YOU
KNOW WITH THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE COUNTIES WITH- ARE
DIFFERENT THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE INVOLVED-
I THINK THAT- ANOTHER THING
THAT IS- YOU KNOW KIND OF
IMPORTANT TO SAY IS THAT WE
ARE. ADJUSTING THEIR RESPONSE
AND- BRINGING THAT STATE FAMILY
TOGETHER TO ANTICIPATE AND THEN
REACT TO IT IN IN YOU KNOW KIND
OF A ONE TEAM ONE FIGHT THIS
VERY COULD HAVE EASILY BEEN-
DIFFERENT AGENCIES DOING
DIFFERENT THINGS. ALL
RESPONDING TO SOMETHING THAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR WORLD AND THAT
REALLY WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT-
THERE COULD BE TREMENDOUS
OVERLAP OR CONFLICT THAT CAN
ARISE WITHOUT WE'RE ALLOCATING
OUR RESOURCES. AND WE KNOW THAT
WE KNOW THAT FROM EXPERIENCE
WITH OTHER KINDS OF EVENTS OR
FOR MANAGING MULTIPLE EVENTS
ALL AT ONCE THAT THE BEST WAY
TO DO THAT IS TO CENTRALIZE AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE UNIFIED
IN OUR STATE SAID THAT WERE
UNIFIED IN HOW RESPONDING TO
YOU. AND TO YOUR CONSISTENT
CONSTITUENTS SO I DO IN ORDER
TO. SO MUCH. AS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE UNDERSTANDING IS
EVOLVING AND WE'RE WILLING TO
AND HAVE ADJUSTED. AS THIS
PANDEMIC HAS EVOLVED AND- ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO A WHOLE
NOTHER- COMPONENT OF IT TO THAT
WILL BE A TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUS- ASSET IN GETTING
PAST THIS PANDEMIC OR AT LEAST
GETTING. IMPROVING THE- OUR
ABILITY TO CONTEND WITH THAT
WHICH IS THE VACCINE PLANNING.
SO ALL OF THAT ADJUSTMENT
HAPPENS IN REAL TIME- IT IS
GOING TO REMAIN A CHALLENGE
FRANKLY TO KIND OF KEEP THAT
THIS- YOU KNOW EVERY CALIFORNIA
AND EVERY ENTITY THAT.
REPRESENTS THEM WHETHER IT'S
PRIVATE SECTOR PUBLIC SECTOR
LAYERS OF GOVERNMENT- YOU KNOW
POSSIBLY IN FRONT OF THE
COMMUNICATION THAT. YEAH OKAY.
OKAY I'M YET MEL. A COUPLE THIS
IS OKAY FOLLOW. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT- MR
GALLAGHER WHO'S ON VIRTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO. ASK A QUESTION
MAKE A COMMENT MISTER GALLAGHER
LET'S HOPE THIS WORKS. ARE YOU
HAVE TO YOU YOURSELF. AND WE
SEE WE SEE AN ICON ON SCREEN
BUT YOU HAVE AND YOU TO
YOURSELF YEAH. IF YOU CAN HEAR
ME.
SURE THE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE- OUR COLLEGE SEEMS TO BE
IMPERSONATING ME WITH MY
INITIALS. WITH THE IT IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HE WOULD HAVE
THE SAME INITIALS. TO OKAY
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU'RE ON
MUTED- IF YOU TALK WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU. SINCE SINCE
WE KNOW USUALLY HAVE NO PROBLEM
TALKING. TO ME I WOULDN'T KNOW
NOW YOU'RE MUTED AGAIN. NO
THAT'S THAT'S WITH CALIBER
WE'RE NOT. MR GALLAGHER C.
FIVE. BOB CHRISTIE JACKET DEAD
JUMPER WITH THE NATIONAL CROSS
OKAY MR GRECO ONE QUESTION WALL
MISTER CALDERON SAVE WHAT YOU
ON TO START TALKING AND WE'LL
TRY TO GET TO YOU RIGHT AWAY.
THE QUESTION REGARDING THE.
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH ON
THE- SCIENTIFIC SAFETY REVIEW
WORK GROUP AND I KNOW MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER COOPER- MADE
THE POINT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN WHAT ROLE WE PLAY IN THE
WRONG VACCINE- I'M CURIOUS. IS
THE VACCINE- SAFETY SIGN
CONSIDER VIEW WORKERS THAT OU
NEED TO CALIFORNIA IS THAT
SOMETHING OTHER STATES ARE ALSO
DOING. AND ESTABLISHING I GUESS
KIND OF THE PROTOCOL REFER
WORDY WITH WHICH TO THE ROLLOUT
OR OR POTENTIALLY BLOCK ACCESS
TO FDA APPROVED VACCINE. THAT'S
LIKE A SPACE MAY LEGISLATION TO
PLAY A ROLE OR MAYBE NOT-
BUNKERS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
BETTER. AWESOME A SCIENTIFIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE I'M AND SO WE
YEAH WE ARE WORKING WITH SOME
OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON OUR
COMMITTEE ARE ALSO WORKING AT
THE NATIONAL LEVEL WE HAVE ACT
THEY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO FTA
INFORMATION REAL TIME WE EXPECT
THAT YOU KNOW WE WOULD. LIKELY
COME TO THE SAME CONCLUSIONS AS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
REVIEWED ALL OF THE DETAIL AND
WE THINK THAT THAT'S THE BEST
WAY TO BUILD TRUST- WE HAVE OUR
OWN CALIFORNIANS IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE LOOKED AT ALL
OF THAT SAME. SCIENTIFIC
INFORMATION AND WE HAVE ACTS
LOOKING UP THAT. THE TUBE THAT
TRUST AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
ACTIVATION CERTAINLY MAKES
SENSE BUT IT JUST KIND OF
BRINGS I GUESS THE QUESTION I'M
ASKING IS YOU CAN UNDER WHAT
AUTHORITY CAN WE DO THAT CAN
STATES- BONTA DOES THAT INVOLVE
THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
SOMETHING THE GOVERNOR CAN DO-
UNILATERALLY- I'VE BEEN I WOULD
HOPE THE EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID
IS TRUE WHICH IS FARTHER SELVES
WHERE WE'RE COORDINATING WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. ARE SOME WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A LOT OF THESE
PAST FEW YEARS BUT HOPEFULLY
WE'RE GOING TO SEE- HERE GOING
FORWARD BUT IN THE CASE THAT WE
DON'T ARRIVE AT THE SAME
CONCLUSION. WHERE DOES THAT
LEAVE US. I THINK WE'RE
EXPLORING THAT ARE ON AND WE DO
HAVE A NUMBER OF LEGAL ISSUES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING INTO. I WE
HOPE THAT WON'T BE THE CASE BUT
IF THAT WERE TO ARISE I THINK
THAT IT WOULD BE MORE ABOUT THE
EDUCATION OF WHAT VACCINE WE
THINK. IS SAFEST AND WHY AND
WHO IT'S SAFE FOR. ON BUT I
THINK THE LEGAL ISSUES ARE
STILL ON. UNRESOLVED AND WE'RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT
HAPPY TO SHARE THAT INFORMATION
AS WE RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES.
OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY MISTER
GALLAGHER. CHAIRMAN PERFECT CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK NOW. SO HOW MUCH
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- FIRST I JUST WANT
TO AGREE WITH. THE REMARKS OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM MERCED- WITH
REGARD TO THE EARLIER PANEL-
WE'VE SEEN GRABBED A GREAT
DISPARITY. BETWEEN THE MONIES
THAT WERE MADE AVAILABLE TO
MORE URBAN AREAS AND THOSE TO
MORE RURAL AND I. I WANTED TO
JUST ADD TO THAT WHAT WE ALSO
SAW. WAS A DELAY IN THE MONEY
GETTING SENT OUT TO THOSE RURAL
COUNTIES AND THAT THAT MONEY
WAS PARCELED OUT SLOWLY. AND IT
WAS GIVEN BUT TO THE URBAN
COUNTIES IT WAS GIVEN AS A
COMPLETE- FUNDING EARLIER IN
TIME. WHICH WAS EXTREMELY
PROBLEMATIC- FOR RURAL COUNTIES
WHO ARE ALREADY SUFFERING.
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND THE
LOSS OF REVENUE. ALL THE SAME.
NEGATIVE IMPACTS THAT- THE
URBAN PARTS OF THE STATE HAVE
EXPERIENCED WE ALL EXPERIENCE
THOSE THINGS- AND TO DELAY THE
CARE IS ACT FUNNY NOW AS WAS
DONE- WAS JUST COMPLETELY
WRONG. NOT TO MENTION THE FACT
THAT THERE IS SUCH A
DISPROPORTIONATE DIFFERENCE. IN
THE FUNDING. YOU'RE LISTENING
TO THAT PANEL I THINK IT IS
IT'S JUST BECOME VERY
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR TO ME. THAT
THERE IS NO PARTNERSHIP
WHATSOEVER. BETWEEN THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
RIGHT NOW. I MEAN WE'VE JUST
HOW MANY TIMES DO WE HAVE TO
HEAR. FROM THE EXECUTIVES THAT
FROM THE AGENCIES THAT THEY
BASICALLY HAVE JUST GONE BEYOND
THE AUTHORITY GRANTED TO THEM
THAT THEY CONTINUE TO SPEND
MONEY WITHOUT YOU KNOW GIVING
THE PROPER NOTICE WITHOUT
HAVING THE PROPER CONSULTATION.
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THERE
CONTINUE TO DO IT THEY JUST
TELL US HERE TODAY. WE'RE SORRY
ABOUT THAT I WILL TRY TO DO
BETTER IN THE FUTURE- BUT THERE
THERE REALLY IS NO PARTNERSHIP
WHATSOEVER THEY KEEP SAYING
THERE'S A PARTNERSHIP. BUT THE
REALITY IS SOMETHING FAR
DIFFERENT AND IT'S I THINK IT'S
TIME FOR US IN THE LEGISLATURE
TO UTILIZE OUR POWER THE POWER
OF THE PURSE WE CAN PULL
FUNDING BACK AWAY FROM THEM WE
CAN- ALSO. SIR OUR OUR POWERS
TO RESTRICT HIS AUTHORITY UNDER
THE EMERGENCY. SERVICES ACT-
NOBODY WANTS TO DO THAT. BUT
WHAT WE'RE CONTINUE TO SEE IS A
COMPLETE ABUSE OF THE AUTHORITY
AND THE MONEY IN THE FUNDING
THAT HAS BEEN GRANTED AND
WITHOUT THE PROPER CONSULTATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
IT'S TIME FOR US TO ACT. NOW
GET INTO THE SECOND PANEL I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS. YOU ARE
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO I WILL
AGREE WITH HIM THAT THE INITIAL
RESPONSE HERE. SAVE LIVES THE
FLATTENING OF THE CURVE.
RESPONSE I THINK EVERYBODY
AGREES WAS THE RIGHT DECISION.
AND HELP TO ENSURE THAT OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WAS PREPARED
FOR THE CASE IS THAT- THAT WE
ALTERNATELY SIDE NOT THEN BUT
IN JULY. JUNE JULY WHEN WE SAW
THE SPIKE IN CASES WE FLATTEN
THE CURVE. ONLY TO SEE THOSE
CASES COME IN JUNE AND JULY. IN
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WAS
BETTER ABLE TO HANDLE IT.
NOBODY UNDERSTANDS THIS
BLUEPRINT METRIC. AND I AND I
AND I AND I JUST WANT TO JUST
SHOW THIS SHOW THIS VERY
CLEARLY FOR EVERYBODY. WHAT
DOES IT MEAN WHEN THEY COUNTY
GOES BACK TO PURPLE RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE GOOD WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE A RISING CASES WHICH
EVERYONE HAD TALKED ABOUT AND
ANTICIPATED WE'RE GOING TO SEE
A RISE IN CASES IN THE FALL
NOBODY I DON'T REMEMBER ANYBODY
SAYING THAT WE WOULD NOT SEE
RISING CASES THIS IS COMPLETELY
ANTICIPATED. AND OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM IS READY TO PROVIDE
FOR AND RESPOND TO THAT RISE.
IN CASES. ONLY SEE THAT RISING
CASES. MANY OF WHICH THE SOURCE
OF THOSE CASES ARE PRIVATE
GATHERINGS. THE RESULT OF GOING
BACK TO PURPLE IS NOT TO GO
FIND THE SOURCE OF THOSE CASES
AND TO TRY TAKE MITIGATING
EFFECTS TOWARDS THOSE ACTUAL
CASES THAT WERE SEEN. NO THE
ARBITRARY COMPLETELY ARBITRARY
RESPONSES TO SHUT DOWN SMALL
BUSINESS AGAIN. WHO'VE ALREADY
BEEN WHO ARE ALREADY ON THE
BRINK OF GOING OUT MANY OF THEM
ALREADY HAVE GONE OUT OF
BUSINESS. BECAUSE OF THE LAST-
SHUT DOWN. AND TO SHUT DOWN
CHURCHES. WHICH ALSO THERE'S
BEEN NO SOURCES OF AN OUTBREAK
DUE TO CHURCH SERVICES
CERTAINLY HAVE NOT SEEN THAT IN
MY REGION. AND SO THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WEE SEEN. THIS
ARBITRARILY SHUT DOWN THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO MEANWHILE EVERY
HOOK EVERY LOAN LOWE'S AND HOME
DEPOT- IN OTHER BUSINESSES THAT
ARE SOMEHOW DEEMED ESSENTIAL
KEEP GOING ON YOU KNOW FULL
BLAST PEOPLE IN THEIR EVERYDAY
SOMETIMES ARE MASSIVE TIMES OR
NOT- YEAH THERE THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO CONNECTION AND
NEXUS TO. THE CONSEQUENCES OF
MOVING BACK TO A PURPLE TEAR
AND WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING
ON THE GROUND. SO I KNOW I
DON'T THINK THAT WHAT WE HAVE
PUT IN PLACE RIGHT NOW THIS
BLUEPRINT IT'S NOT SAVING LIVES
IT'S ACTUALLY MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY HURTING LIVES.
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING RISES IN
IN SUICIDE WE ARE SEEING RISE
IN YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH A 60%
INCREASE IN BUTTE COUNTY AND
USE USE NEEDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- WE ARE SEEING. PEOPLE
NOT GOING INTO GET CARE- THAT
THEY NEEDED AND IN HOSPITALS
AND HEALTHCARE FACILITIES- THE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS BLUEPRINT.
METRIC FAR OUTWEIGH ANY
BENEFITS THAT IS PROVIDING. AND
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO HEAR I
MEAN. ANYBODY IN PUBLIC HEALTH
CAN TELL ME HOW IN THE WORLD.
THAT IT MAKES SENSE THAT THAT
THE THAT THE RESPONSE SHOULD BE
TO SHUT DOWN SMALL BUSINESSES
AND CHURCHES. AND THAT SOMEHOW
THAT IS GOING TO MITIGATE.
LEAVING EVERYTHING ELSE OPEN
ESSENTIALLY LEAVING ALL OTHER
THINGS OPEN- YES WE'RE TELLING
PEOPLE NOT TO GATHER PRIVATELY
BUT THEY'RE STILL DOING IT- YOU
KNOW SO. THE ONLY PEOPLE THEY
GET PUNISHED ON YOUR SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW. OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
CHURCHES. YOUR NAIL SALONS-
RESTAURANT THE RESTAURANT
OWNERS THAT'S WHO ENDS UP
GETTING AS A PRACTICAL MATTER
SHUT DOWN INTO THE SYSTEM AND-
AND FEEL THE FULL BRUNT OF THIS
ARBITRARY RESPONSE MEANWHILE
NOTHING ELSE HAPPENS CASES
STILL GO UP- AND WE AND WE
MANAGE THEM JUST LIKE WE DID
LAST TIME. AND SOMEHOW THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE A RESPONSIBLE
WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS
I'M SORRY I DON'T SEE IT AND
NONE OF MY CONSTITUENCY. SO I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM PUBLIC
HEALTH HOW IS IT I MEAN IT ALSO
IS VERY BIASES OF EVENT
COUNTLESS CONVERSATIONS WITH
YOU. BIASED AGAINST RULE AREAS-
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S GOING TO
BE A NEW WORLD METRIC BUT IT
DOESN'T TAKE AWAY FROM THIS%
ARBITRARY NATURE. OF THE
RESPONSE- AND HOW IT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS ONLY CERTAIN PARTS OF
SOCIETY AND ONLY CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES. IT DOESN'T SEEM TO
HAVE ANY REAL NEXUS TO.
RESPONDING TO THE CASES THAT
WERE SEEN ON THE GROUND. AND IS
IT ANY WONDER WHY WERE SEEN
PEOPLE JUST NOT FOLLOWING. I
MEAN I WOULD LOVE ANY RESPONSE
THAT MAKES ANY KINDOF SENSE-
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH. AND AGAIN
WE HAD NO WE AS THE LEGISLATIVE
BODY OF HAD ABSOLUTELY NO INPUT
INTO THIS. AB HAVE NO ABILITY
TO ESTABLISH A EVEN THOUGH THAT
WE ARE THE LAW MAKING BODY OF
THE LAND BUT- ONE GROUP OF
BUREAUCRATS IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
IS TO DECIDE THIS ISSUE FOR
EVERYBODY. THROUGHOUT SOCIETY
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THERE'S
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION SO PLEASE.
EXPLAIN TO ME WHY YOUR METRIC
MAKES ANY KIND OF SENSE. AND
HOW ARE RESPONDING TO THIS
CRISIS. SO I WILL START AND SAY
THAT THE BLUEPRINT IS DESIGNED
TO ENSURE A SLOW PROGRESSION
FORWARD TO LIMIT THE MOBILITY
ACROSS THE STATE WE ONLY HAVE
SO MANY TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX OF
WHAT WE CAN. DO TO SLOW THAT
MOBILITY AND YOU'RE RIGHT WE
WISH THAT EVERYBODY WOULD HE
ADHERE TO THE M. HE EYES THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE THE MASKING THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING THE
LIMITATION ON HOUSEHOLD
GATHERINGS. BUT THERE ARE
INDEED YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
CAUSING TRANSMISSION BUT
TRANSMISSION IS BEING CALLED IN
SOME OF THESE OTHER SETTINGS AS
WELL AND AS WE DO FURTHER AND
FURTHER RESEARCH AND COLLECT
INFORMATION ON OUTBREAKS THERE
ARE EXAMPLES OF OUTBREAKS IN
SOME OF THESE OTHER SECTORS AS
WELL. RETAILERS THAT YOU HVE
BUT I AM SOME OF THE
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER THINGS SO
WE'VE TRIED TO DO A RISK
ANALYSIS AND LOOK AT WHERE WE
CAN OPEN MORE SAFELY AND AS YOU
PROGRESS THROUGH THE TEARS. TO
CONTINUE TO OPEN ON BUT AS YOU
MOVE BACK WE THINK THAT YOU
KNOW IT IS ESSENTIAL TO LIMIT
THAT MOVEMENT SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP TRANSMISSION DOWN AS MUCH
AS POSSIBLE- WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE THE SMALL COUNTY METRIC.
NOVEL BUT LOOKS AT ON ACTUAL
CASES RATHER THAN CASE RATE TO
ALLOW A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY
IN OUR RURAL COUNTIES WE HAVE
LOOKED AT OBSERVATION PERIOD SO
THAT WE COULD SEE IF DATA WAS
TRENDING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WE- WERE ON WE'VE WAITED A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE
MOVING BACK TO THE SMALL
COUNTIES- AND GIVE THEM TIME TO
SORT OF. ADJUST TO MINOR
FLUCTUATIONS IN THEIR DATA SO
WE ARE VERY MUCH COMMITTED TO A
SLOW RE OPENING OF CALIFORNIA
TO KEEP THE TRANSMISSION DOWN
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE- YOU KNOW
IT'S IT IS AT A ONE FOR ONE
MATCH FOR EVERY SECTOR AND
EVERY. TEAR AND EVERY BUSINESS
NOW BUT WE'RE DOING OUR BEST TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE LIMITING OF
MOBILITY ACROSS THE SECTORS.
DOES HELP TO REDUCE
TRANSMISSION. FOLLOW UP ADD TO
THAT. EVEN IF I'M FOLLOWING
YOUR REASONING AND YOU'RE
TRYING TO LIMIT MOVEMENT WHY
JUST RESTAURANTS YEAH WHY JUST-
BARBER SHOPS NAIL SALONS- I
MEAN CERTAINLY THERE'S MOVEMENT
IN LARGE BIG BOX STORES I MEAN.
THERE'S NOTHING IN YOUR METRIC
THAT SHUTS THEM DOWN. I'M SURE
THERE ARE PEOPLE YOU KNOW THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE CONTINUING
TO TRAVEL TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE AND I'M HAND PLEASE
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT YOU
BECOME MORE RESTRICTIVE PLEASE
DON'T READ THAT IN MY COMMENTS.
AT ALL BUT IF THAT'S TRULY THE
CASE HOW COME THERE'S NO
RESTRICTION ON ON TRAVEL- TO
DIFFERENT. TO DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND LOOKING AT OTHER-
SECTORS OF THE ECONOMY THAT
ALSO RELY ON MOVEMENT. AND
PEOPLE GATHERING IN IN CERTAIN
PLACES- I GET IT IT MAKES NO
SENSE YOU'RE ONLY FOCUSING ON
ONE PART OF THE COMMUNIST IT IS
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HURT
THE MOST. THROUGHOUT SINCE
MARCH THEY'RE THE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE BEEN SHUT DOWN MULTIPLE
TIMES. AND I ARE GOING TO GO
SHUT THEM DOWN ONCE AGAIN. I
MEAN I HATE TO KEEP USING IT
BUT LOWE'S AND HOME DEPOT OR
OPEN RECORD YEARS. RECORD YEARS
AND THE SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE ARE GETTING DESTROYED.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND LIKE YOU
KNOW HOW DID YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER YEAH. WE DO HAVE TO
HURRY UP SURGED IF YOU ASK A
QUESTION PRECIADO IT AND THEN
TRY TO GET OUT FROM THE
SPINELLI. WELL I MEAN STOP THE
SIMPLE QUESTION IS WHY DOES
THIS APPLY TO. MANY OTHER
SIMILAR TYPE OF INDUSTRIES
ACROSS THE BOARD YOU'RE ONLY
FOCUSING. ON RESTAURANTS NAIL
SALONS SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT'S
WHO HAS TO SHUT DOWN WE GO BACK
TO PURPLE. AND YOU'RE TELLING
PEOPLE CAN GATHER IN THEIR
CHURCH. EVEN THOUGH NONE OF
THOSE THINGS AND MAKE CONNECTED
OUTBREAKS. FIRST OFF START BY
SAYING SOME OF THOSE THE EIGHT
WE ARE SEEING EVIDENCE OF
OUTBREAKS AND SOME OF THOSE
FACTORS THERE ARE ALSO A LOT OF
OTHER SECTORS THAT CAN'T OPEN
UNTIL WE GOT TO- EITHER THE
ORANGE OR YELLOW TIER SO IT'S
NOT JUST A FOCUS ON SOME OF
THOSE BUSINESSES BUT- I'M WE
AGREE THAT SOME OF THOSE
BUSINESSES ARE. DO POSE SOME
RISKS WHERE PEOPLE CAN'T BE A
MATH CAN'T NECESSARILY BE
DISPENSED- AND THEN WE HAVE TO
MEASURE AND BALANCE THAT WITH
SOME OF OUR CENTRAL SERVICES
WHERE PEOPLE DO NEED TO GET
FOOD AND DO NEED TO GET OTHER
THINGS JUST TO DO THAT TO BE
ABLE TO CONDUCT DAILY LIFE SO I
THINK THAT. IT'S A BALANCING
ACT THERE'S NO PERFECT ANSWER
ON BUT WE'RE DOING THE BEST WE
CAN TO TRY TO- SLOW THE
MOVEMENT AND TO SLOW
TRANSMISSION AND SO WE CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THAT WE HAVE
ALLOWED AND MORE THINGS AS WE
LOOK AT THE RISK ADJUSTMENTS
AND LOOK AT. HOW ON BUSINESSES
HAVE COME TO US AND EXPLAIN HOW
THEY CAN OPEN MORE SAFELY WE
HAVE MOVED SOME THINGS BACK
INTO PURPLE HERE AND ALLOW THEM
TO OPEN ON ME AND SO I THINK
IT'S A CONTINUING DIALOGUE ON
AND WITH THE BUSINESS SECTORS
WE'VE TRIED TO WORK VERY
CLOSELY ACROSS THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND EACH OF THE
BUSINESS SECTORS TO UNDERSTAND-
WHAT THEY CAN PUT IN PLACE WHAT
ON AND. CONTINUE TO MODIFY OUR
GUIDANCE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION FOR MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MEGA MOVES TO
THE NEXT AND I'LL MAKE IT REAL
QUICK AND THIS IS FOR- MISS
FANELLI- ONE OF THE TOPIC THAT
COMES UP. IN MANY OF OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES IS OUR- US SNIFFS
IN THOSE- RESIDENTIAL HOMES
THAT CONTINUE TO HAVE HIGHER
RATES. THE THROW OFF OUR
SMALLER COMMUNITIES NUMBERS AND
THEREFORE CLOSING SOME OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES- WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO I MEAN. WE SEEM TO
HAVE A HOT BED IN SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR THOSE. AND
NUMBER ONE- WOULD BE GREAT TO
HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY WITH-
THOSE NUMBERS THAT DON'T AFFECT
THE REST OF COMMUNITY. COLLEGE
AND IF I AM SURE YOU'VE BEEN
THIS IS FROM BROUGHT UP
NUMEROUS TIMES BUT- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE HAVE ONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND YELLOW COUNTY
THAT HAVE LIKE FIFTY CASES OF
POSITIVE AND- REALLY THREW OFF
THE ENTIRE COUNTY. AND I'M SURE
THIS IS HAPPENING IN OTHER
RURAL COMMUNITIES BUT- AGAIN-
IF YOU COULD JUST KIND OF.
ANSWER THAT AND THEN ALSO I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU I KNOW
THIS IS TOUGH. THESE THE THIS
IS SOMETHING NEW TO ALL OF US
AND WE HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS
BUT- AS- SO MY COLLEAGUES SAID
OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES. ONE
PLACE TO THE TABLE. AND SO
WE'RE HERE. TODAY SO WE ARE
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH ON
OUR SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
ON OUR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES WE HAVE A- I
HEALTHCARE ACQUIRED INFECTIONS
TEAM INFECTION PREVENTION US
THAT PROVIDE. ON A CONTINUING
ON SITE HELP AS WELL AS A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE VIRTUALLY.
I'M WE DO LOOK AT EACH OF THOSE
FACILITIES TRY TO WORK. ON
MITIGATING THOSE OUTBREAKS WE
PUT IN. PLACE A NUMBER OF
THINGS LIKE SERIAL TESTING OF
STAFF. TO TRY TO VERY QUICKLY
GOT ON TOP OF- ANY YEAH WE KNOW
THAT. THE TRANSMISSION IS
HAPPENING LARGELY THROUGH STAFF
COMING INTO THE FACILITIES. AND
SO TRIED THAT TESTING OF STAFF
GOT FROM EARLY INDICATOR OF-
ANYBODY WHO IS IN FACT THAT-
AND ALLOWS US TO COHORT AND-
YOU HAVE- ISOLATE QUARANTINE
THAT STAFF SO THAT WE CAN
REDUCE TRANSMISSION. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT- THOSE NUMBERS
DO YOU SORT OF IMPACT A SMALL
COUNTIES IN BIGGER WAYS. GIVEN
THE NUMBERS THAT COULD BE AND
IN FACT IT. I HOWEVER WE DO
THINK THAT IT DOES LEAD TO
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION AND BACK
AND FORTH BECAUSE THEY- THE
STAFF PEOPLE AND OTHERS ARE
BACK AND FORTH INTO THE
COMMUNITY AND SO WE HAVE NOT-
BEEN YET. SORT OF LOOKING AT
WAYS TO AND TAKE THOSE NUMBERS
OUT. BUT RATHER TO WORK TO VERY
QUICKLY MITIGATE THAT IMPACT
AND- ALTHOUGH IT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON ON CASES FOR. A FEW
DAYS OR A WEEK WE ARE HOPING
THAT WE CAN GET THAT QUICKLY
UNDER CONTROL AND BRING IT
BACK. I'M TO GET THOSE NUMBERS
BACK. WE DO HAVE AN
ADJUDICATION PROCESS WHERE
PEOPLE CAN MAKE A CASE. IF
THERE'S A PARTICULARLY.
IMPACTFUL SITUATION AND WE WILL
EVALUATE. THAT ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS. THANK YOU LET ME
JUST THANK THE- PANELISTS FOR
PARTICIPATING ALSO JUST THANK
THEM ALL FOR THEIR HARD WORK WE
REALLY DO. I MUCH APPRECIATED
AND WE ALL. WORKING TOGETHER
AND TRYING TO- YOU KNOW GET OUT
GET A HOLD OF THE SITE
PANDEMICS ARE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED ONE COMMENTS. ARE
WE ARE NOT GOING TO THE NEXT
PANEL I'M GOING TO ASK THAT
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE ARE SHORT
ON TIME. IF THEY COULD JUST
LIMIT THEIR STATEMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES MAXIMUM. AND THEN WE
COULD MAKE SURE WE LEAVE ROOM
FOR QUESTIONS SO WE HAVE W.
DIRECTOR SHELL FROM DTS. THE B.
DIRECTOR SHALL EITHER. AND YOU
CAN GO AHEAD AND START YOU HEAR
ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OKAY
IN THE INTEREST OF SAVING TIME-
I WILL GO RIGHT TO THE QUESTION
ABOUT- THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
FOR PROCURING- THE CRITICAL PP
ITEMS THAT WERE NEEDED BY THE
STATE- DGS PUT TOGETHER- DUE TO
THE FACT THAT WE WERE DIRECTED
TO PROCURE LARGE CACHES OF PP
AND TARGET AMOUNTS WE DID PUT
TOGETHER A SPECIAL BOOK
PROCUREMENT TEAM THAT WILL
FOCUS SOLELY ON PROCUREMENT OF
PP- WE USED TO BE A COVERT
NINETEEN WEBSITE- THE MEDICAL
SUPPLY CONTRIBUTIONS PORTAL
THAT WAS LAUNCHED ON APRIL
FOURTH TWO VET VENDORS IN THE
SYSTEM- IT WENT THROUGH MULTI
PHASED PROCESS. AND ONCE THE
LEADS WERE VALIDATED THEY WERE
SENT TO THE BULK PROCUREMENT
TEAM FOR FINAL PURCHASE. THE
ONES THAT LEAD WAS FORWARDED TO
THE PROCUREMENT TEAM THEY USE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS TO
DETERMINE IF A PROCUREMENT
COULD BE EXECUTED. VENDORS WERE
ASKED TO PROVIDE A QUOTE WITH
PRICING DELIVERY SCHEDULES
COPIES OF PRODUCTS
SPECIFICATIONS AND DEPENDING ON
THE BY CHAIN OF CUSTODY
INFORMATION SUCH AS LOCATION
THE MANUFACTURE. STORAGE
FREIGHT FORWARDER FOR OUT OF
COUNTRY PURCHASES AND ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
NECESSARY VENDORS WERE ASKED TO
PROVIDE A PAY DATA RECORD THAT
INCLUDED BUSINESS INFORMATION
SUCH AS FEDERAL TAX ID.
BUSINESS ENTITY TYPE IN
RESIDENCY STATUS. BYERS THEN
TOOK THAT INFORMATION AND THEY
EVALUATED QUOTES TO DETERMINE
REASONABLE PRICING AGAINST BOTH
TARGET PRICING AND PRICING OF
OTHER VENDORS THAT WERE SELLING
SIMILAR PRODUCTS. TIMELY
DELIVERY SCHEDULES PRODUCTS
MEETING SPECIFICATIONS AND
WHETHER A CHAIN OF CUSTODY WAS
ACTUALLY ESTABLISHED. BUYERS
AND EVALUATED PAY DATA
INFORMATION THROUGH REVIEW OF
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WEB
PORTAL FOR BUSINESSES IN GOOD
STANDING. VERIFICATION OF
WEBSITES FOR SUPPLIERS AND
THEIR SUPPLY CHAINS OUT OF
STATE BUSINESS PORTALS THAT
COULD PROVIDE INFORMATION ON
THE STANDING OF THE VENDOR AND
FISCAL INFORMATION FOR OUR
EXISTING BUYERS. I'M SORRY
VENDORS HE'S ME BUYERS ALSO
ENSURED MANUFACTURERS AND
PRODUCTS WERE ON THE FDA'S
ESTABLISHMENT AND REGISTRATION
DEVICE LISTINGS. BUYERS
LEVERAGED HELLO YES IS HOMELAND
SECURITY UNIT TO VET SUPPLIERS
THAT REQUESTED UNUSUAL PAYMENT
TERMS OR A VENDOR INFORMATION
COULD NOT BE READILY VALIDATED.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO OUR
COUNTERPARTS ARE BECOMING
COUNTERPARTS IN OTHER STATES TO
IDENTIFY EXPERIENCES THEY WERE
HAVING WITH SIMILAR VENDORS.
BUYERS THE NEGOTIATED WITH
VENDORS ON PRICING PAYMENT
TERMS AND DELIVERY SCHEDULES
AND PURCHASE WORK PURCHASES
WERE DISCUSSED WITH THE CHIEF
PROCUREMENT OFFICER IN MOST
INSTANCES INSTANCES BEFORE
EXECUTION OF THAT PURCHASE. IF
ANY OF THESE EVALUATIONS. WERE
UNSUCCESSFUL THE BY WAS
DECLINED. BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
AVAILABLE PP CAPACITY WITHIN
THE U. S. MOST OF THE PURCHASES
WERE COMING FROM CHINA. MANY OF
THESE WERE DEALERS OR BROKERS
WHO ARE OFTEN ESTABLISHED
BUSINESSES BUT NOT FORMALLY IN
THE BUSINESS OF SELLING PP.
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT GET
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO CHINESE
MANUFACTURERS TO BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH THEM DIRECTLY. AS AN
ALL STATE CONTRACTS THE VENDOR
WAS HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ENTIRE PROCUREMENT FROM
EXECUTION OF THE PURCHASE ORDER
TO FINAL DELIVERY AN INSPECTION
AT STATE WAREHOUSES. WHILE THE
STATE WORK WITH VENDORS ENSURE
PRODUCTS WERE PROVIDED AS
COMMITTED TO VENDORS THAT COULD
NOT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS HAD
THEIR PURCHASE ORDERS
TERMINATED OKAY IF YOU COULD
DATE THE STATE HAS TERMINATED A
TOTAL OF FIFTY THREE PURCHASE
ORDERS. MICHELLE IF YOU COULD
WRAP UP THAT BE GREAT IT WILL
DOUBLE SURE WE WILL GET TO YOU
GET FRESHEN. THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU. I WE HAVE NOW.
DIRECTOR MEDICAL WHICH. THANK
YOU ARE- CHAIRMAN HOWARD GRAY
AND CHAIRMAN CHANG IT'S A
PLEASURE TO SPEAK WITH FOR YOU
AND I'LL MAKE THIS AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE I SIMPLY WANT TO
ELABORATE ON MY COLLEAGUES-
WORK THERE. THAT THEY DID IN
THE PROCUREMENT SIDE HOUSEHOLD
HERE AND THAT'S JUST PART OF
THIS JOURNEY THAT WE ENGAGED IN.
WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT WOULD
NOT ONLY BE BOUGHT THIS TO WE
WERE HOW'S IT HOW DO WE
DISTRIBUTED HOW DO WE ACCOUNT
FOR. AND HOW DO WE SUPPORT ALL
OF OUR CUSTOMERS- TOGETHER IN A
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT APPROACH.
WORKING TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY WITH NOT JUST
WITH OUR STATE AGENCY PARTNERS
BUT OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AS
WELL AS- OUR FEDERAL. PARTNERS
AS WELL SO. ALL THIS IS A BEEN
IN EXTREMELY DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING- BUT I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT- WE HAVE OVERCOME
THOSE OBSTACLES. AND PUT US IN
A GREAT POSITION GOING INTO
THIS NEXT WAVE- THOSE SHORTAGES
THAT WE EXPERIENCED IN PP. 95%
OF THOSE OBJECTIVES HAVE BEEN
HAVE BEEN PURCHASED AND
PROCURED VETERANS STOCKPILE
NOW. AND WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
ONE LINE ITEM. WERE IN A VERY
GOOD POSITION GOING INTO THE
NEXT WAVE AND TO SUPPORT THE
FLU- THE PROJECT SHELL TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW WE VETTED
THESE THIS PROCESS BUT WE DID
THIS. IN A TIMELY MANNER WITH.
OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND. VENDORS
AND FOLKS THAT WANTED TO COME
TO US TO ACTUALLY- EITHER SELL
THEIR GOODS OR PROVIDE
DONATIONS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- ALL THE STONE WAS
METHODICALLY DELIBERATELY. AND
DONE IN A WAY TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY OF FOR ALL
INVOLVED. I DO WANT TO SAY.
THAT WE NOW ARE. A
DISTRIBUTING- APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND ITEMS A DAY IF YOU
LOOK BACK ON THE HISTORY OF THE
SITE- PANDEMIC WITH US WHEN WE
MOVED OVER EIGHT OR NINETY
THREE MILLION PIECES OF PP. TO
ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES A WITH
A THE STATE OF. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU ASKED WAS
HOW DO WE WORK SCARCE RESOURCES
AND I WANTED TO ELABORATE THAT
WE DO THAT THROUGH WHAT THEY
CALL A MULTI AGENCY
COORDINATION GROUP. IT'S
ESTABLISHED IT'S METHODICAL AS
WELL THE USES A MATRIX IT'S
MADE UP OF MULTIPLE MEMBERS AND
THEY GO THROUGH AND LOOK AT A
REQUEST IN DETAIL IN ADJUDICATE
AND ALLOCATE RESOURCES WHEN
THEY BECOME SCARCE. FOR
FORTUNATE NOW THAT THAT- MAC
GROUP HAS BEEN DEMOBILIZED
THAT'SBECAUSE WE HAVE TAKEN
THE NECESSARY STEPS TO ADDRESS
SUPPLY CONSTRAINTS- IN OUR
SYSTEM. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO THANK YOU AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MISS
PETERS MISS PETERS WITH OIL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- I'LL BE BRIEF
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME- IT
WITH REGARD THE PP IS SIMILAR
TO THE STATE'S OVERALL
EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES
ADMINISTRATION HAS CONSIDERABLE
FLEXIBILITY TO PROCURE.
SUPPLIES AS IT RESPONDS TO
EMERGENCIES. ON ANTI DO THINGS
SUCH AS- SUSPENDING. EXISTING
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT I'M
REGULATIONS AND LAWS TO PROVIDE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY TO THE
MINISTRATION. I'M AND SO WE
HAVE JUST PUT TOGETHER SOME
OVERSIGHT QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY WANT TO ASKING YOUR
REMAINING TIME ON FUTURE I'M
HEARINGS. I'M LOOKING AT THE
OVERSIGHT OF PP. SO AND IN THE
INFORMATION. THAT I AM HAS BEEN
BETWEEN. LAST YEAR AND PLANNED
FOR THIS YEAR AN ESTIMATED FOUR
PP. AND OTHER SUPPLY
PROCUREMENT. IT'S UNCLEAR FROM
THAT HOW MUCH IS FOR PP VERSUS
OTHER TYPES OF SUPPLIES. AND SO
EVEN JUST GETTING THAT AND
SENSE OF A NUMBER OF WHITE WHAT
EXACTLY AND HOW IS THE FUNDING
AMOUNT FOR PP WILL BE
IMPORTANT. HOW MUCH HAS ALREADY
BEEN SPENT VERSUS HOW MUCH IS
PLANNED TO BE SPENT. ON AND
WHAT AND WHAT DOES THE STATE
HOPES TO ACHIEVE WITH THOSE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS THAT IT HAS
ESTIMATED FOR THE REST OF THE
YEAR. IN TERMS OF- NUMBER OF
SUPPLIES AND TYPES OF SUPPLIES.
HOW DOES NOT ALIGN WITH THE
CURRENT DEMAND FOR PP. I'M AND-
I'M HOW HAS THE PP THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN PURCHASED AND
DISTRIBUTED VERSUS HOW-
ADDITIONAL PROCUREMENTS WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND I'M REALLY HOW
REQUEST FOR PP ARE BEING
EVALUATED AND PRIORITIZED- WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IF SUPPLY AND IF
THE SUPPLIES. CAN'T ARE UNABLE
TO MEET TIME DEMANDS IF THERE'S
REALLY GREAT DEMAND FOR PP. I'M
HOW OLD PRIORITIZATION BE MADE.
HAVE ANY REQUESTS. FOR PP BEEN
DENIED TO DATE. I'M THANK. LIKE
AND LIKE I SAID THE- AND- PP
PROCUREMENT LIKE OTHER KIND.
AWARDED DURING EMERGENCY CAN BE
EXEMPTED FROM REGULAR
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS.
HOWEVER WERE AT THIS STAGE OF
THE PANDEMIC RESPONSE WHERE THE
MINISTRATION DOES HAVE MORE
TIME TO PLAN. FOR ITS
ACTIVITIES AND SO WHAT TO WHAT
EXTENT IS THE STATE FOLLOWING
REGULAR CONTRACTING
REQUIREMENTS. OR TRYING TO
INCORPORATE ELEMENTS OF THOSE
SUCH AS COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENT. I'M INTO ITS
PURCHASE OF PP NOW THAT THERE'S
MORE TIME TO PLAN FOR THESE
PURCHASES. ON AND AGAIN WELL
IT'S NOT REQUIRED BY STATE LAW-
IS THE ADMINISTRATION GOING TO
NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE IN
ADVANCE OF MAJOR PP PURCHASE
SAYS SO AT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S- PLANS ARE.
THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS.
THANK YOU. I WON'T NEED TO
LEAVE IN A FEW MINUTES ARE
GOING TO TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
MISTER GRAY WHO I THINK HAS
SOME OPENING QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU- TO THE PANEL AND OUR
PANELISTS FOR. BEING HERE WITH
US TODAY. I WANT TO TOUCH FOR A
MINUTE ON THE FOR FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD THEIR SUPPLY
RESTRAINTS. HAVE BEEN RELIEVED.
NOW IS THAT APPLIED JUST. TO P.
P. E. AS AND MASKS AND GLOVES
SUTTER- WHERE WE AT ON TE
DISCUSSION AROUND FOR EXAMPLE
VENTILATORS AND HOSPITAL
CAPACITY RIGHT AND ARE WE
PROPERLY UTILIZING- MAYBE KIND
OF A BREAK IN THE ACTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA
FACE SIMILAR ISSUES IN THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE- WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH. OF ANYTHING.
THEY START THEIR. I THINK THAT
WOULDBE A GOOD QUESTION TO
DIRECT TO- YES AND EGS IN TERMS
OF THEIR PLANNING ACTIVITIES
FOR ADDITIONAL- PEACE OF MIND.
WELL PERHAPS WE CAN HEAR FROM-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR THEY GIVE EACH.
YES THANK YOU ADJOURNMENT- SO
WE WORK HAND IN HAND IN CONCERT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH ON ANY THE MODELING THAT
THEY HAVE AS WELL AS LOOKING
BACKWARDS INTO WHAT. THE TOTAL
NUMBERS OF COMMODITIES AND
TYPES THAT WE DISTRIBUTED OUR
PREVIOUSLY- IN IN THE PAST WAVE
AND NEEDS TO FAX GIVE US OF
PLANNING TARGET AND WHAT WE CAN
WORK TOWARDS- SO I WILL SAY IS
THAT- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ESTABLISH A METRIC AND THEN BY
IN STOCKPILE TO THAT METRIC. SO
THAT WE PUT OURSELVES IN A
POSITION WHERE WE HAVE-
SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES TO PUSH
THROUGH THIS NEXT WAVE- THE
ONLY- THAT WE'VE RECENTLY BEEN
EXPERIENCING ANY CHALLENGES HAS
BEEN AND GLOVES THIS IS AN AREA
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
AGGRESSIVELY ON IT'S NOT THAT
IT'S HURTING US. IN OUR ABILITY
TO. MAINTAIN THE CURRENT
DISTRIBUTION IT IS NOT THAT IT
HAS NOT MET OUR TARGET FOR LONG
TERM STOCKPILING WITH THE
ADVENT OF SB TWO SEVENTY FIVE
WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO AND SEE IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THIS. A
PANDEMIC THAT WILL IMMEDIATELY
ROLL OVER INTO THAT STOCKPILE
AND PREPARES FOR ANY OTHER
FUTURE HAZARD OR EMERGENCY THAT
MAY TAKE PLACE- IN TERMS OF A
VENTILATOR SO WHICH WAS BROUGHT
UP- WE'VE ALSO PROCURED
VENTILATORS ON BEHALF OF- EMSA.
AND HAVE DONE SO IN A POSITION
TO MEET OUR TARGETS THERE TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
VIOLATORS- AND WE'VE ALSO
PROCURED NECESSARY SUPPLIES TO
BILLS SURGE CAPACITY FOR
HOSPITALS THAT ARE. WOULD BE A
PORTABLE IN NATURE WE WOULD
ESTABLISH IN COLOCATION OF FOR
THAT SURGE CAPACITY SO ALL OF
THESE ELEMENTS HAVE BEEN DONE
BY THE LOGISTICS AND COMMODITY
TASK FORCE IT'S A MULTI AGENCY
TASK FORCE AND WE WERE CAN HEAD
TOGETHER- TO DO THAT- I'M
GONNA. LET A DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SHALL ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
REGARDING- PRICING AND. HOW
THAT DOES WORK THERE SO STAND
BY. THANK YOU. SO WITH RESPECT
TO- THE PLAN GOING FORWARD- WE
ARE WORKING ON A COMPETITIVE
PROCUREMENTS AT THIS TIME-
WE'RE CURRENTLY EVALUATING FOR
AWARD A COMPETITIVE MULTIPLE
VENDOR PROCUREMENT FOR AND
NINETY FIVE AND SURGICAL MASKS
THAT WE BELIEVE WILL SUPPLY-
THIS ITEM FOR THE NEXT YEAR AND
UP TO TWO ADDITIONAL YEARS SO
THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
THE STOCK- ON HAND NEEDED TO
RESPOND TO ANY THE CONTINUANCE
OF THIS EVENT OR ANY FUTURE
EVENTS THAT COME UP- WE ARE
ALSO WORKING ON OTHER AREAS IN
LOOKING AT GOING BACK TO. OUR
COMPETITIVE PROCUREMENT METHODS
RECOGNIZING THAT OBVIOUSLY THIS
WAS AN EMERGENCY- PROCUREMENT
OPERATION AND WE WANT TO MOVE
AWAY FROM THAT AND GET BACK TO
OUR NORMAL PROCUREMENT
OPERATIONS. LET ME GO DOWN A
LITTLE FURTHER AND- I WORK
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW WE'RE
VETTING THAT THERE WERE SOME
REFERENCE TO. BROKERS AND
SPECIFICALLY THE NEED TO
ACQUIRE. SUPPLIES FROM OVERSEAS
AND- THAT KIND OF THE BIGGEST
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING POST
PANDEMIC OR OR IN THE MIDST OF
THIS PANDEMIC TO- FOR SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT OVERLY RELIANT
OVERSEAS IN THERE IS
MANUFACTURING ON. THE SUPPLIES
AND OTHER THINGS AND IMAGE
FINDER ACCOUNTABLE WHAT WHAT
THE- PROTOCOLS WERE. OUR SAFETY
MEASURES THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE-
IN AROUND BROKERS FOR EXAMPLE
COULD A BROKER YOU GET A
CONTRACT WITH THE STATE TO
ACQUIRE PP FROM CHINA AND AT
THE SAME TIME- CONTRACT PP
FROM. YOU KNOW LOS ANGELES AND
THEN WHEN THE- SUPPLIES COME IN
FROM CHINA JUST TAKE A WALK ON
THE COMPANY THAT THEY PROCURED
HERE LOCALLY- DO WE HAVE ANY
OVERSIGHT THAT AREA BECAUSE IT
SOUNDED TO ME LIKE OUR
RELATIONSHIP IS. MORE SAY
EXCLUSIVELY BUT PRIMARILY WITH
THE BROKER AND WHATEVER'S
HAPPENING WITH THE SUPPLIERS-
WE DON'T KNOW WE'RE NOT A
CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITY FOR IS
THAT A FAIR COMMENT. WE WHO WE
CONTRACTED WITH ALL ALL START
WITH WITHOUT LAST PORTION OF
THE QUESTION. THE STATE.
CONTRACTS WITH A SINGLE VENDOR-
OR UNDER NORMAL PROCUREMENT
OPERATIONS ARE ALLOWED TO BE
JOINT VENTURES AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS- BUT IN THIS THIS
EMERGENCY PANDEMIC WE ARE
CONTRACTED WITH A SINGLE VENDOR
THAT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN A BROKER- BUT OUR
EXPECTATION WAS THAT THAT.
BROKER OR THAT BUSINESS ENTITY
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL FACETS
OF THE OPERATION FROM A
SUBMITTING THE QUOTE TO
IDENTIFYING THE CHAIN OF
CUSTODY CUSTODY TO ENSURING
THAT- THE GOODS WERE DELIVERED-
TIMELY- TO THE LOCATION THAT
WAS REQUESTED- INVOICES WERE
SUBMITTED AND PAYMENTS WERE
MADE- AND SO. TRADITIONALLY THE
STATE AGAIN CONTRACTS WITH A
SINGLE VENDOR AND IF THERE ARE
CHALLENGES TO- THE FURTHER
SUPPLY CHAIN AT THE STATE DOES
ATTEMPT TO WORK WITH THOSE
THOSE WHAT WE WOULD CALL PRIME
VENDORS TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PAYMENTS ARE BEING MADE VENDORS
ARE BEING YOU KNOW RESPONSIBLE
AND THOSE SORTS OF THINGS- BUT
AGAIN OUR OUR CONTRACT IS WITH-
THAT SINGLE VENTURE VENDOR WITH
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- AND IN
THE CASE. BACK TO YOU KNOW WILL
NOT RUNNING FOR STATISTICALLY
RELIABLE DOWN OF NO I'M SORRY
GIVEN INTERRUPTER AND ECHO FOR
YOU'RE SAYING MAKE. TO WORK
WITH SUPPLIERS BUT IN THE CASE
WHERE. A CALIFORNIA COMPANY-
CAME FORWARD SAID HEY YOU KNOW
YOU GUYS CONTENT VENDORS THEY
CONTRACT WITH ME THEY DIDN'T
PAY ME- IS THERE ANY RECOURSE.
FOR THAT COMPANY UNDER THE
CURRENT PROCESS. AGAIN BECAUSE
THE STATE IS CONTRACTING
DIRECTLY WITH A C. VAN THAT IS
WHERE OUR CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP LIES AND SO. IF WE
HAD INSTANCES WHERE THERE WERE
A LOT LOWER TIERED SUPPLY CHAIN
VENDORS INDICATING THAT THEY
HAD NOT BEEN PAID WE
IMMEDIATELY WORKED WITH THAT
PRIME VENDOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE TAKING CARE OF. ALL
OF THE VENDORS IN THE IN THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WITH RESPECT TO
PAYMENT AND ANY OTHER ISSUES
THAT MAY HAVE COME UP. OKAY
THANK YOU. AND THEN ONE LAST
QUESTION NUMBER TO MOVE ON IT
MEMBERS- WHAT'S THE PROCESS.
FOR VETTING THOSE. BROKERS. SO
AS I TOUCHED ON A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER IN LOOKING AT VETTING
WE HAD SEVERAL STEPS THAT WE
USED- IN TERMS OF VETTING OUR
VENDORS- AND YOU KNOW WE LOOKED
AT THE INFORMATION. SUCH AS A
CHAIN OF CUSTODY- YOU KNOW
WHERE THEY IN ESTABLISHED
BUSINESS EITHER IN OUR CURRENT
OF FISCAL SYSTEM THE FINANCIAL
AND ACCOUNTING INFORMATION
SYSTEM- IF NOT WERE THEY WHEN
THEY SUBMITTED A- PAY DATA
STATEMENT- DID IDENTIFY YOU
KNOW WHAT THEIR BUSINESS
INFORMATION WAS WAS THERE A
FEDERAL TAX ID- YOU KNOW WAS
THERE A NON YOU KNOW TAT WHICH
WOULD STILL BE A FEDERAL TAX ID
BUT YOU KNOW SO SECURITY NUMBER
VERSUS A AND F. B. I. AND- YOU
KNOW WHAT WAS THE TYPE OF
BUSINESS ENTITY WORTHY IN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE PORTAL- IF
THEY WERE OUT OF STATE BY WERE
WE ABLE TO VALIDATE IN OTHER
STATES. SIMILAR PORTALS THAT
YOU KNOW THEY WERE A REGISTERED
BUSINESS IF THEY WERE OUT OF
COUNTRY WE WERE ALSO ABLE TO
GET DOCUMENTATION TO SHOW THAT
THEY WERE AN ESTABLISHED
BUSINESS IN AND OUT OF COUNTRY
ELEMENT AS WELL- A LOT OF THESE
ENTITIES THAT WE DID BUSINESS
WITH- MAY HAVE BEEN BROKERS BUT
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED
BUSINESSES- BUT THEY MAY NOT
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN THE
PPP BUSINESS A LOT OF VENDOR
STEPPED UP. TO TRY AND
ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS OF NOT
JUST THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BUT THE NATION AND OTHER
COUNTRIES AS WELL AND SO THIS
STATE HAD TO DEAL WITH AN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF VENDORS
THAT WE HAD NOT HEARD OF BEFORE
SO WE DID DO THAT VETTING
PROCESS AND WE DID MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAD LEVEL OF
INFORMATION THAT WOULD ALLOW US
TO BE ABLE TO HOLD THIS VENDOR-
YOU TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CONTRACT AND BY AND LARGE WE
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT YEAH WE
DID HAVE SOME VENDORS AS I
STATED EARLIER THAT WE HAD TO
TERMINATE. BUT IT WAS MOSTLY
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THEY COULDN'T MEET THE DELIVERY
DEADLINES THAT WERE SO CRITICAL
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THEY COULDN'T MEET THEM BECAUSE
THE SITUATION IN THE- THE
SUPPLY CHAIN WAS JUST UNHEARD
OF IT WAS IT WAS PEOPLE YOU
KNOW SELLING OUT GOODS
UNDERNEATH EACH OTHER IT WAS
SUCH LIMITED SUPPLY- AND YOU
HAD ASKED EARLIER AND ALL ALL
ALL AND WITH THIS BUT YOU ASKED
EARLIER ABOUT WHAT THE STATE
WAS DOING TO TRY AND- AWAY FROM
USING OUT OF COUNTRY- OR YOU
KNOW JUST RELYING SOLELY ON
CHINA. AND WE DID WORK WITH
SEVERAL COMPANIES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALONG WITH
OUR PARTNERS AT- YES- AND GO
BASE TO. SEE IF WE COULDN'T GET
OTHER MANUFACTURERS OR VENDORS
TO STEP UP AND RETOOL THEIR
OPERATIONS. OR START SELLING-
PP AND WE DID HAVE SOME
INSTANCES. WHERE WE HAD OAKLEY
STEP UP AND START PRODUCING
FACIALS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HAD A
COMPANY OUT OF LOS ANGELES YOU
STRIVE. THAT STEPPED UP AND
RETOOL THEIR OPERATION TO MAKE
A CLOTH FACE MASKS ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SO. WE DID HAVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL. OKAY
THANK YOU- THIS TIME REMOVED
TO. A CELL NUMBER COOPER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. WHAT HAPPENS
IF THE DEMAND EXCEEDS SUPPLY
PP. IS THERE A PRIORITIZATION
PLAN FOR PP DISTRIBUTION. AND
WILL LEGISLATURE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THAT PLAN.
YEAH I THANK YOU A MEMBER
GRAVERT I WOULD SAY THAT- I
KNOW HOPE IS NOT A METHOD BUT
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO FOR
SELF THE POSITION I THINK WE'VE
TAKEN THE NECESSARY STEPS- TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT SUPPLIES IN OUR
STOCKPILE- TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING- WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH LEGISLATURE- IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS- BUT RIGHT NOW LIKE
I SAID BEFORE WE USE THAT MULTI
AGENCY COORDINATION GROUP THE
MAC GROUP. OF THAT LITERALLY
TAKES A VERY DEEP DIVE WHEN
REQUEST COMES IN AND ENSURES
THAT THE REQUEST IS NOT A
PADDED ANYWAY AS CRITICALITY-
THE FUNCTIONALITY OF THAT
REQUEST IS PROPERLY JUDICATA
AND BY DOING SO THEY'RE ABLE TO
MAKE A NORMAL DISTRIBUTION OR
GOOD DISTRIBUTION TO THAT TO
THAT GROUP TO MEET THE- THE
NEEDS OF CRITICALITY THAT
NEEDS- AND THAT'S THAT'S
CURRENT METHODOLOGY IS BEING
USED IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL TO
DATE- THERE ARE AND WITH THAT
OF COURSE MEANS THAT A REQUEST
YOU KNOW MAY COME IN TO BE
REDUCED- TO MEET THEIR MOST
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS ARE NEEDS
MAYBE IT'S YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
A THIRTY DAY SUPPLY. YOU GET A
TWO WEEK SUPPLY OR MAYBE MEANS
WE'LL GET A TO EXPLOIT WE GET A
ONE WEEK SUPPLY WHILE 
HANDLE OTHER CRITICAL AREAS.
WOOD MISTER. OKAY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
WITH THAT ALL THANK OUR
PANELISTS FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING- PRECIADO- NOT ALL YOUR
ANSWERS TODAY BUT ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU DO ON BEHALF OF ALL
THE NUMBERS. AT THIS TIME
MEMBERSTO CONCLUDE OUR HER
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND I SEE THAT WE
HAVE SEVERAL- INDIVIDUALS HERE
IN THE GALLERY. I'M NOT SURE OF
ALL THREE OR FOUR OR FIVE
PEOPLE ACCOUNT TESTIFYING I
WILL SAY WE HAVE VERY LIMITED
TIME HERE- THE CHAMBERS IS
GOING TO HAVE TO BE- CLEANED
AND TIPS DISSIPATION OF THIS
AFTERNOON'S HEARING SO IF YOU
COULD. STATE YOUR NAME AND
QUICKLY- PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY
LESS THAN A MINUTE WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO. WELL WE'VE GOT FIVE
MINUTES SO DEPENDING ON HOW
MANY FOLKS WANT TO TESTIFY-
WILL DIVIDE THAT TIME AMONGST
OURSELVES WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
EVERYBODY IF POSSIBLE. IN THE.
THE NEW YORK TIMES. SHE CANNOT
GUARANTEE A. ALL. OKAY THANK
YOU. YES MICROPHONE ISSUES ARE
BEING RESOLVED CHECK. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JOANNA HEDRICK WE MUST
HAVE TRANSPARENCY AND THE
ABILITY TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROCESS WHEN I TRIED TO ENTER
THE BUILDING TODAY I WAS TOLD
THE BUILDING WAS CLOSED TO THE
PUBLIC. UNDER THE PREP ACT THE
HOBBIT VACCINE MANUFACTURERS
ARE EXEMPT FROM LIABILITY. THEY
ARE TESTING THEVACCINE ON ONLY
HEALTHY INDIVIDUALS YET IT'LL
BE USED ON A POPULATION. WHERE
54% OF AMERICANS HAVE CHRONIC
ILLNESSES THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THESE TRIALS.
PEOPLE LIKE MYSELF WITHOUT
MONTH SO YOU'RE GOING TO
MANDATE A VACCINE. THAT'S NOT
TESTED ON THE PEOPLE THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE USED ON ANY MANDATE
OF A COVERT VACCINE WOULD
VIOLATE BODILY AUTONOMY. THIS
IS NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORY
PEOPLE WHO DISSENT FOR SPEAK
OUT ARE NOT GIVEN RESPECT AND
ARE BEING CENSORED. WHEN YOU
GET TO THE POINT OF USING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST THE PEOPLE
THEY ARE MEANT TO PROTECT. THE
FORCED A VACCINE WITH ZERO
LIABILITY I JUST IMPLORE USED
ALL TO ASK THE HARD QUESTIONS.
WAS IT TESTED AGAINST AN INERT
PLACEBO HOW DOES THE GENERAL
POPULATION COMPARED TO THE
POPULATION IN THE TRIALS OF THE
VACCINE RISKS OUTWEIGH THE
RISKS OF THE ILLNESS. PEOPLE
MUST HAVE INFORMED CONSENT FREE
OF COERCION. I HAVE A BACHELOR
OF ARTS DEGREE FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO IN
PHILOSOPHY LOGIC AND THE
PHILOSOPHY OF SCIENCE I'M
CURRENTLY SEEKING A MASTERS OF
SCIENCE DEGREE. FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF MARYLAND IN
BALTIMORE. THROUGH THE SCHOOL
OF PHARMACOLOGY. I'M NOT STUPID
I CAN READ FINE. YOU HAVE TO
INCLUDE THE PUBLIC IN THESE
DECISIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC TESTIMONY
THIS TIME. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND PROVIDED TESTIMONY.
HELLO I'M TONY CARTER. AND THE-
CORONAVIRUS OKAY LESS LETHAL
THAN THE FLU. ARE YOU ENJOYING
THIS PLAN TO MAKE. NO WAY WE
ARE MANDATING ISOLATING. SOCIAL
DISTANCING. STAIN SIX FEET
APART WEARING MASK. ACCEPTING
TOKEN GIFTS INSTEAD OF BEING
ABLE TO WORK BECAUSE OF A
CORONA VIRUS. LET'S GET REAL.
YOU WANT TO TAKE OUR RIGHT TO
BE SOVEREIGN WAY. FROM GOOD
HARD WORKING AMERICANS YOU
SCARE THE HECK OUT OF PEOPLE
BEHIND THE LIES SPEWING OUT OF
THE MOUTHS OF THOSE WHO DO NOT.
HAVE THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
REPREHENSIBLE LESS PEOPLE HAVE
DIED YEAR TO DATE AS A RESULT
OF THIS PLAN DAMAGE. NOW KOBE
NINETEEN DOES SCARE THE ****
OUT OF ME. IT SHOULD SCARE THE
**** OUT OF ALL OF YOU. COVE IT
STANDS FOR CERTIFICATE OF
VACCINE IDENTIFICATION. NO
FREEDOM WITHOUT THE VACCINES.
WHY ARE YOU WILLING TO SELL
YOUR CHILDREN'S FREEDOM FOR A
LITTLE COMFORT NOW. YOU PEOPLE
MAKE ME SICK GOOD LUCK TO YOUR
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN OKAY. YOU
CAN'T HIDE FROM GOD. MY FAMILY
FOR THE LAST HUNDRED YEARS HAS
SERVED IN THE MILITARY. YOU
KNOW THE GUINEA PIGS FOR THE
VACCINES OF THE PAST. I
PERSONALLY CAN SPEAK TO THE
LONG TERM GENETIC DISABILITIES
IN ABNORMALITIES. OUR FAMILIES
ARE ALL BEING BORN WITH ISSUES.
MY MOM SITTING OVER THERE HAS
HAD OVER TWENTY SURGERIES. SHE
CAN'T. SHE CAN'T WALK THROUGH
THE METAL DETECTOR WITHOUT.
SETTING THEM OFF DUE TO THE
PROSTHETICS SHE WAS BORN WITH
HIP. BONE ABNORMALITIES
ABNORMALITIES HER FATHER WAS A
THIRTY YEAR VETERAN OF THE NAVY.
HE WAS FORCED VACCINATED AND
CHIN AND HIS CHILDREN ARE
PAYING THE PRICE. FOR THAT IN
THE NAME OF THE GREATER GOOD
WHOSE GREATER GOOD THAT MY
BROTHER HAS DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND MENTAL ILLNESS
I WAS BORN WITH BIRTH DEFECTS
REQUIRING SURGERY. AS WELL AS
MY CHILDREN. WHEN DO WE GET TO
SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH. MY FAMILY
MY HUSBAND HIS FAMILY HAS ALSO
SERVED THIS COUNTRY FOR
GENERATIONS MY HUSBAND IS A BET
OF A- PERSIAN GULF WAR. AND A
RETIRED DEPUTY HIS FAMILY HAS
ALSO HAD SIMILAR ISSUES. BUT
DIED OF CANCERS HONESTLY YOU
WANT TO COMPLY. HONESTLY YOU
WANT TO COMPLY YOU GO RIGHT
AHEAD JUST REMEMBER I WILL DIE
BEFORE YOU GET ANYWHERE NEAR ME
WITH ANOTHER VACCINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THE. TIME HAS EXPIRED
HERE NOW SEEING TWELVE TWELVE
TWENTY ONE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE KNOWS THE
PUBLIC MAY ALSO SUBMIT AT ANY
ADDITIONAL RISK WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO. YEAH YEAH. SO
JUST HOW MANY ADDITIONAL- FOLKS
DO WE HAVE. WE ARE HAPPY TO-
CONSIDER SOME ADDITIONAL TIME.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU YELLING
THAT COULD GET YOU ARE WE'RE
GOING TO SEE WE CAN DO TO WORK
THROUGH HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY. YEAH. AS.
FIRST WE WILL PROVIDE. OKAY.
LET ME CONFIRM WITH THE
SERGEANTS AND SEE IF WE CAN GET
AN ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES
WHICH WOULD ALLOW FOR THE THREE
INDIVIDUALS TO SPEAK IS THAT.
WELL THAT GIVE EVERYONE MORE
THAN A MINUTE. OKAY WE'RE GOING
TO EXTEND ADDITIONAL FIVE
MINUTES SO THAT WE CAN AFFORD
TO KIRSTY THE FOLKS THAT TAKE
THE TIME TO BE HERE TO SPEAK I
WOULD POLITE. FOR I WOULD.
REQUEST WE TRY TO KEEP OUR
COMMENTS TWO ONE MINUTE. THE
SERGEANTS WILL. I. HELLO THE
NEXT INDIVIDUAL TO DUST WILL
GIVE A ONE MAN FOR THE FOR
INDIVIDUALS HERE WHO TALKED
FINANCIAL TESTIMONY PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND GIVE YOUR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
KATHERINE MCBRIDE. THERE IS NO
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY IT'S AN
OUTBREAK THE VIRUS HAS OVER 99%
RECOVERY RATE THERE ARE
EFFECTIVE. THERE PUNITIVE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT
WE NEED TO OPEN UP OUR
BUSINESSES AND SCHOOLS. THIS
PANDEMIC IS RUINING OUR ECONOMY
AND FAMILY TO BECOMING
ESTRANGED EIGHT MONTHS AFTER
THE INITIAL LOCKDOWN NOT MUCH
HAS CHANGED BUT WE THE PEOPLE
HAVE THAT TIME TO OPEN OUR EYES
AND SEE. THAT WE ARE BEING
PLAYED. ASKED DON'T WORK. DEATH
NUMBERS ARE MANIPULATED AND
TESSAR INACCURATE. THE MEDIA IS
COMPLICIT IN SPREADING
WIDESPREAD FEAR AND LYFT. OUR
CONSTITUTION IS HERE TO PROTECT.
OUR FREEDOM WE ARE FREE PEOPLE.
AND TO BE CLEAR THERE IS NO
PLACE EVER FOR MANDATORY
VACCINES. INCLUDING SCHOOL
CHILDREN NURSES AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
ACT EXAMS. MANUFACTURERS FROM
LIABILITY AND WHERE THERE IS
RISK THERE MUST BE CHOICE STOP
THE LIES STOP THE LOCKDOWN AND
STOP THE MANDATES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC.
CAN
YOU GUYS PAY ATTENTION FOR A
SECOND ONE THOUSAND MEMBER IF
YOU COULD JUST BE CLOSE TO THE
MICROPHONE WE COULD HEAR YOU.
THE MESSAGES ON THE OKAY SO
LET'S FIRST. THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY YEAR OVER
THERE LATER TO LISTEN. THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR BABIES
KILLED EVERY DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS. FORTY NINE DAYS IF I
TAKE IT INTO CONSIDERATION BUT
SO FAR WE HAV EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND AND TWENTY ONE THAT
PEOPLE FROM COVERT. SO LET ME
ASK YOU A QUICK QUESTION. WHEN
ARE WE GONNA HAVE A PANDEMIC
FOR KILLING BABIES. EXCUSE ME.
NOBODY. SO LET US MOVE REPLY.
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR BUT
TEN MONTHS. I BET YOU THE
NUMBER HE'S WAY MORE THAN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND AND CHANGE.
BUT YOU GUYS ARE JUST SITTING
ON YOUR HANDS AND NOT DOING
ANYTHING FOR THAT NOTHING.
RIGHT ARE YOU OKAY ARE YOU OKAY
TO KILL THIS MANY BABIES. AND
THEN YOU TELL US THAT THERE'S A
PANDEMIC AND EVERYBODY'S
FALLING DOWN ON THE STREETS
DYING I'M SORRY I DON'T HEAR
ANYONE I DON'T SEE ANYONE. DO
YOU. YOU WANT TO FORCE
VACCINATORS. YOU WANNA LOCKERS
DOWN ARE YOU OKAY WITH ALL THE
SUICIDES WHICH ARE RISING OUT
OF PROPORTIONS. YOU TOO JIM.
WHY DON'T YOU PAY ATTENTION
BECAUSE I BET YOU LEVELED UP
WHEN YOUR VIDEO GAME BY YOU
WERE LISTENING TO YOUR BODY'S
SHUTTING HERE FOR THE PAST
THREE HOURS. THAT'S RIGHT JIM I
VOTED ON YOU AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WAS ONE OF MY BIGGEST
MISTAKE WHAT I DID. BECAUSE YOU
DON'T DESERVE TO BE THERE I AM
NOT. USE ONE MINUTE IF YOU
COULD SEND THESE GUYS ROB I'M
NOT ON THAT DESERVE TO BE
SITTING IN THOSE CHAIRS BECAUSE
IF YOU ARE PART OF WE THE
PEOPLE. THEN THIS IS A JOKE
WHAT YOU HAVE DONE HERE TODAY.
ONE BIG JOKE OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS AS ARE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS I SEE WHAT.
WE CAN REFRAIN FROM YELLING IN
THE CHAMBERS WILL GET TO THE
FOLKS THAT WANT TO TESTIFY. HI
HI GUYS I ENJOYED HEARING ME
BUDGETING THE DISCUSSION OF
BUDGETING- I JUST WONDER WHY DO
WE NOT TALK ABOUT EIGHTEEN U.
S. CODE TEN THIRTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN U. S. CODE TEN THIRTY
EIGHT DEALS WITH FALSE
INFORMATION AND HOAXES. IT
TALKS ABOUT HOW IF INFORMATION
PRESENTED. HAS A REASON TO BE
BELIEVED LIKE. STATEWIDE MASS
GUIDANCE- AND LOCKDOWNS FOR
INSTANCE. BUT IS FALSE IN
NATURE YOU CAN BE PROSECUTED
FOR YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY LYING.
MINIMUM YOU CAN BE FINED OR
IMPRISONED IN PRISON FOR AT
LEAST FIVE YEARS OR BOTH. IF
BODILY HARM. IS CAUSED BY THE
MISINFORMATION. THE SENTENCE
GOES FROM FIVE YEARS TO TWENTY
YEARS. SO LIKE THE PEPLE
PASSING OUT FOR WEARING THE
MASKS THE PEOPLE COMMITTING
SUICIDE. OR THAT LOVELY FUTURE
VACCINE THAT YOU GUYS CAN'T
STOP TALKING ABOUT. LASTLY IT
DOES OCCUR DURING THE VIOLATION
OF CODE TEN THIRTY EIGHT YOU
CAN EARN A LIFE SENTENCE IN
PRISON. OH WAIT I REMEMBER
THOSE SUICIDES THAT I MENTIONED
UNDERNEATH OF SERIOUS BODILY
HARM AND THE TWENTY YEAR
IMPRISONMENT THAT'S PROBABLY
BELONGS HERE NO PROBABLY
BELONGS HERE IN MY OPINION
SPREADING FALSE INFORMATION IN
THE FORM OF A PANDEMIC SOUNDS
LIKE TO THOSE THAT HAVE TAKEN
THEIR LIVES THOSE TWENTY ONE
YEAR OLD LIKE ME THAT HAVE
KILLED THEMSELVES IN THE LAST.
EIGHT MONTHS. DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE HE'S ASSISTING THEM TO
KILL THEMSELVES IF THEY'RE
TERRIFIED OF SOMETHING THAT
ISN'T HAPPENING. HOW MUCH SO
HOW MUCH MONEY MY QUESTION IS
HOW MUCH MONEY ARE YOU GUYS
GOING TO BUDGET FOR THIS. WHY
ISN'T IT ON THE HANDOUTS HERE
WHY IS IT ON THEIR OWN. AND THE
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION IS WHY
AREN'T YOU ALL IN HERE EVERY
SINGLE ONE YOU BUY THE TABLE
WHY AREN'T YOU IN HANDCUFFS FOR
YOUR PARTICIPATION IS GLOBAL
SCANDAL. WHEN ARE WE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THIS AND WHAT. WHAT
ARE WE GOING TO BUDGET FOR IT.
THANK YOU. OKAY WITH THAT WE'VE
CONCLUDED OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. I WANT TO REMIND
EVERYONE THAT YOU CAN SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS VIA EMAIL
WILL GIVE- THAT OPPORTUNITY ONE
WHO WASN'T ABLE TO SPEAK IN
TODAY WITH THAT MEMBERS OF THE-
COMMITTEE MEETING IS ADJOURNED.